I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hello everyone. Hi.
我是珍娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们正为你们制作终极的《办公室》粉丝播客。每周，我们将通过独家采访、幕后细节和许多闺蜜故事，深入探索《办公室》的世界。我们是《办公室女士》6.0版。大家好。嗨。
Welcome to Office Lady 6.0. Today we are going to be discussing all things food on the office. So behind the scenes, in the scenes, you're going to hear from some of our cast members about their food memories. Plus, Sergio Giacoman, our awesome caterer is going to be with us later on in the episode. He's going to tell us all about his time feeding the cast and crew of the office. Yes. It was so wonderful talking with him. He has such fond memories of the show. And, you know, there were some pretty epic food moments that happened at Dundermifflin. We're going to need to discuss those. And some unbelievable food content I found in the bonus features on the DVDs. I can't wait to share. Here's a teaser. One involves a Dundermifflin employee who starts a cooking show. Uh-huh. And the other are some food PSAs that John Krasinski did for NBC. Well, lady, I might have found something in my digital clutter. You said that, and I can't believe it. Like, you have digital, first of all, you have digital clutter.
欢迎来到《办公室女士》6.0版。今天我们要讨论《办公室》里关于食物的一切。在幕后和镜头前，你们将听到一些演员分享他们的美食记忆。此外，我们出色的餐饮服务商塞尔吉奥·贾科曼稍后也会加入我们的节目。他将讲述他为《办公室》剧组提供餐饮的时光。是的，和他交谈真是太棒了。他对这部剧有着非常美好的回忆。而且，你知道，在邓德·米夫林发生过一些非常经典的食物时刻。我们需要讨论一下。我还从DVD的奖励花絮中发现了一些令人难以置信的食物内容。我迫不及待想分享了。先给你们透个底。其中一个涉及一位邓德·米夫林的员工开始做烹饪节目。嗯哼。另一个是约翰·卡拉辛斯基为NBC拍摄的一些食物公益广告。好吧，女士，我可能在我的数字杂物里发现了一些东西。你这么一说，我简直不敢相信。首先，你居然有数字杂物。
And secondly, it's about food. Okay, I'll explain it all when we get to it. But first, we have a very special guest in the studio with us today and also a loyal office ladies listener. And you are smiling. I am. Yes, because today's guest is my husband and an amazing self-taught. Chef and Baker, Joshua Snyder.
其次，这和食物有关。好吧，等我们聊到那儿时我会解释清楚。但首先，今天演播室里有一位非常特别的嘉宾，他也是《办公室女士》的忠实听众。你正在微笑。我是。是的，因为今天的嘉宾是我的丈夫，一位了不起的自学成才的厨师和烘焙师，约书亚·斯奈德。
Welcome, Josh. Thank you, thank you guys so much. Oh, man, it's surreal to be here because I am such a fan of you guys in the podcast. And so it's just like to actually be here. I'm like, oh, my gosh, it's crazy. He's here. He has listened to every single episode of Office Ladies. Every episode.
欢迎，乔什。谢谢，非常感谢你们。天哪，能来到这里真是太不真实了，因为我是你们和这个播客的超级粉丝。所以能真的来到这里，我感觉，天哪，这太疯狂了。他来了。他听过《办公室女士》的每一集。每一集。
Including our second drinks. Oh, second drinks are great. I love the second drinks. I love the top show you guys do with the second drinks. Yeah, he's very encouraging. He's like, I like, I like the second drinks. tidbits. Yeah, and re-listening to it has been great. I've, like, rediscovered how much I love your podcast all over right now. Oh, come on. It's great. He should do ads for office
包括我们的“第二杯饮品”环节。哦，第二杯饮品太棒了。我喜欢第二杯饮品。我喜欢你们做的关于第二杯饮品的顶级节目。是的，他非常支持。他说，我喜欢，我喜欢第二杯饮品的趣闻。是的，重听这些节目感觉很棒。我现在重新发现了我是多么喜欢你们的播客。哦，别这样。这太棒了。他应该为《办公室》做广告。
things. I agree. Well, we thought it would be a really fun way to kick off this food episode by talking with you, Josh, and Angela, because the two of you had a cookbook come out yesterday. Yes. October 21st, your new cookbook called You Can Make This. It came out yesterday. It's very surreal to us. We're like doing press for it. We're on the Today Show. I mean, it's been a whirlwind and it's so, I'm so happy it's finally out too. It's been such a long time coming, you know? We've been working on this cook. You guys know, writing a book takes a long time, like a lot longer than you think it does, you know? Yeah. No, when we very first decided, okay, we're going to take all of our favorite recipes. You know, we had the YouTube baking with Josh and Ann Show and then
我同意。好吧，我们觉得以一种非常有趣的方式开启这期美食节目，就是和你以及安吉拉聊天，因为你们俩昨天刚出版了一本食谱。是的。10月21日，你们的新食谱《你可以做这个》昨天出版了。这对我们来说非常不真实。我们正在为它做宣传。我们上了《今日秀》。我的意思是，这简直是一场旋风，我很高兴它终于出版了。这真的经历了很长一段时间，你知道吗？我们一直在制作这本食谱。你们知道，写一本书需要很长时间，比你想象的要长得多，你知道吗？是的。不，当我们最初决定，好吧，我们要把我们最喜欢的食谱都收集起来。你知道，我们之前有YouTube上的《与乔什和安一起烘焙》节目，然后
Josh has been curating recipes for years on our website. And we were like, it's time to do our cookbook. And I was like, babe. And I told him, Jenna, what you told me. You're like, you're going to pitch this book. In three years, you'll hold it in your hand. It's so accurate, too. I mean, I was like, seriously, it's going to take that?
乔什多年来一直在我们的网站上整理食谱。我们当时想，是时候出我们的食谱了。我对他说，亲爱的。我告诉他，珍娜，你告诉我的话。你说，你要推销这本书。三年后，你就会把它拿在手里。这太准确了。我的意思是，我当时想，真的吗，需要那么久？
I can't imagine it taking that long. You know, it's like, I have the recipes ready to go. Like, what else is there? What's the hold on? This is amazing, Angela, you were me in the cookbook. the way I was with our book. I was like, oh gosh, buckle in, lady. Buckle in.
我无法想象需要那么久。你知道，就像，我已经准备好食谱了。还有什么？为什么会耽搁？这太神奇了，安吉拉，你在食谱这件事上就是我。就像我对待我们的书一样。我当时想，哦天哪，系好安全带，女士。系好安全带。
There's going to be revisions, photography. So many revisions. A lot of people are going to weigh in on things you never even imagine you'd be talking about font size and color and yeah. Well, this cookbook is such a lovely reflection of the two of you. I have said this before, but my kids always get so excited to come to your house for dinner or when you come to our house and they know you're going to bring something. because the food's always so great, and also your home is just so welcoming, and I really felt that in the cookbook. Can you guys share a little bit about how you started this food journey? I mean, my memory of you two dating and hearing from Angela was that you were always
会有修改，摄影。太多的修改了。很多人会对你从未想过会讨论的事情发表意见，比如字体大小、颜色等等。好吧，这本食谱真是你们俩的可爱写照。我以前说过，我的孩子们总是很兴奋能去你们家吃晚饭，或者当你们来我们家时，他们知道你们会带点什么。因为食物总是那么棒，而且你们的家也非常温馨，我在食谱里真的感受到了这一点。你们能分享一下你们是如何开始这段美食之旅的吗？我的意思是，我对你们约会时的记忆，以及从安吉拉那里听到的，就是你们总是
kind of in the kitchen. Well, yeah, I mean, I, here's the thing. Josh was always whipping up some dessert that all the moms at the school were talking about. He would bring these sugar cookies for events, and they looked like works of art, but they also tasted really good. So I was like, who's this guy? Yeah, I mean, I started like making the cookies and cakes, you know, when the kids were small. And I think mostly I was a doubt on a budget, you know, so I wanted to be able to give them what they wanted for their birthday, you know, and, you know, they wanted, like, a Nizago cake or like some sort of, like, themed character cake. I wanted to be able to do that for them. So, and, you know, cakes are expensive at the store. So I, you know,
在厨房里忙活。好吧，是这样的。乔什总是会做出一些甜点，学校里的妈妈们都在谈论。他会为活动带去这些糖霜饼干，它们看起来像艺术品，但味道也非常好。所以我当时想，这家伙是谁？是的，我的意思是，我开始做饼干和蛋糕，你知道，是在孩子们还小的时候。我想主要是因为我是一个精打细算的爸爸，你知道，所以我希望能给他们想要的生日礼物，你知道，他们想要，比如一个尼扎戈蛋糕或者某种主题角色蛋糕。我希望能为他们做到这一点。所以，你知道，店里的蛋糕很贵。所以我，你知道，
really thought that I could just, you know, make it myself. This is very much him being also just like his family. They just do it themselves, you know? They're Kansas and Colorado, and they're just going to figure it out. They're not going to pay someone to do it for them. Well, very Midwest, right? Yes, yes. I mean, all of your stories about St. Louis, I'm like, oh, yeah, that's, that's, that's, that's, that's
真的觉得我可以自己做。这非常像他，也像他的家人。他们就是自己动手，你知道吗？他们来自堪萨斯州和科罗拉多州，他们就是会想办法解决。他们不会花钱请别人来做。好吧，非常中西部，对吧？是的，是的。我的意思是，你所有关于圣路易斯的故事，我都觉得，哦，是的，那是，那是，那是，那是
Kansas. That's the same, it's the same thing. So, yeah. But I, it started out like it's just a hobby, really. And then as I got more into it, I got more into it. I got more gear, and then all of a sudden I'm the person with, you know, two drawers of different icing tips. You know, I'm like, who, what happened to me?
堪萨斯。是一样的，是一样的。所以，是的。但它开始时真的只是一个爱好。然后随着我越来越投入，我投入得更多。我买了更多的装备，然后突然之间，我就成了那个拥有，你知道，两个抽屉不同裱花嘴的人。你知道，我当时想，谁，我怎么了？
I don't know. Well, you made those cakes and cookies then for my kids' birthdays. You made some for Mindy's daughter. Like, you started then, people were like, hold on. Because a lot of times, like you said, Ange, they look good, but they don't taste good. Josh's stuff is both. Yeah. And, you know, I think for you, too, Josh, like baking is.
我不知道。好吧，你当时为我孩子们的生日做了那些蛋糕和饼干。你还为明迪的女儿做了一些。就像，你开始做之后，人们就说，等等。因为很多时候，就像你说的，安吉，它们看起来不错，但味道不好。乔什的东西两者兼备。是的。而且，你知道，我觉得对你来说，乔什，烘焙就像是
kind of like your Zen garden. Absolutely. It's like where you go to relax. Absolutely. And actually, it's funny because this cookbook, I did so much of this cookbook listening to Office Ladies. Because I'm a huge audio book person, a podcast person. And I would say, I mean, the majority of these recipes, I was listening to an Office
你的禅意花园。绝对是。这是你放松的地方。绝对是。而且实际上，这很有趣，因为这本食谱，我做了很多是在听《办公室女士》时完成的。因为我是一个超级有声书迷，播客迷。我想说，我的意思是，这些食谱中的大部分，我都在听《办公室女士》
Ladies episode or two. Wow. You're welcome. Thank you. Office Ladies is a huge part of this book. We're in the book. We're in the book. I like it.
的一集或两集。哇。不客气。谢谢。办公室女士是这本书的重要组成部分。我们在书里。我们在书里。我喜欢这个。
And here's the other thing, too, is not only his job. a great baker, but he's also a great chef. So one of the things, we have a busy household. We have lots of kids. They always have friends over. So we're big on easy dinners and great snacks and breakfast and lunches. So there's really everything in here. And we wanted it to feel like you were just coming home with us and hanging out. Yeah. And Angie did such a great job with the personal stories, you know, because every recipe does have a story because it means something to us. It's there's something that we've, you know, we make all the time in our house or was, you know, my grandma's recipe or her grandma's recipe. And Anne just had a way of like, you know,
还有一件事，不仅是他的工作。他是一位出色的烘焙师，但他也是一位出色的厨师。所以其中一件事，我们有一个忙碌的家庭。我们有很多孩子。他们总是有朋友过来。所以我们非常喜欢简单的晚餐和很棒的零食、早餐和午餐。所以这里面真的什么都有。我们希望它让你感觉就像和我们一起回家，一起闲逛。是的，安吉在个人故事方面做得非常好，你知道，因为每个食谱确实都有一个故事，因为它对我们有意义。这是我们，你知道，在我们家里经常做的东西，或者是，你知道，我奶奶的食谱，或者是她奶奶的食谱。安吉有一种方式，你知道，
writing the book to make it feel like you're part of our kitchen and part of our family. Well, you know, are. Yes, exactly. And I did take a nod to our book, Jenna, because I love that we had a back and forth. So we did that with our cookbook. If there was a recipe that was special to Josh, he would write a little thing or I would write a little thing. So you have this back and forth. But I'm just so excited also for our kids to have this book. It really feels like our home to me. I hope everyone likes it. There's beautiful food photography. I want to give a shout out to Victoria Harris and her whole team. But then there's also these candid pictures of us in our life and our home. Yeah. Our kids grew up in the kitchen too. And these are the recipes
写这本书让你感觉你是我们厨房的一部分，也是我们家庭的一部分。好吧，你知道，你是。是的，完全正确。而且我确实向我们的书致敬了，珍娜，因为我喜欢我们有来回的互动。所以我们在食谱里也做了这一点。如果有一个食谱对乔什来说很特别，他会写一点东西，或者我会写一点东西。所以你有这种来回的互动。但我也非常兴奋我们的孩子能拥有这本书。它对我来说真的感觉就像我们的家。我希望每个人都喜欢它。里面有精美的食物摄影。我想向维多利亚·哈里斯和她的整个团队致敬。但里面还有我们生活和家里的坦诚照片。是的。我们的孩子也是在厨房里长大的。这些就是
that they grew up with. And so I'm so happy that we have this keepsake for them. Besides, you know, putting it out for everyone else, this for our kids was really important. for us to have these, you know, these are the recipes we grew up with. Yeah. Well, and, you know, just to wrap up, one of the reasons we named the cookbook, you can make this is because I am not a natural in the kitchen. I'm pretty much a hot mess in the kitchen, and Josh would always say to me, you can make this.
他们从小吃到大的食谱。所以我很高兴我们为他们留下了这个纪念品。除了，你知道，把它发布给其他人，这对我们的孩子来说真的很重要。对我们来说，拥有这些，你知道，这些是我们从小吃到大的食谱。是的。好吧，你知道，最后总结一下，我们给食谱命名为《你可以做这个》的原因之一是因为我在厨房里不是天生的。我在厨房里简直是一团糟，乔什总是对我说，你可以做这个。
And he would also say that to our kids. Like, they would try a recipe, and you'd be like, guys, you can make this. So when it came time to name the book, I was like, babe, we have to call it. You can make this because that's what you say to us all the time. Yeah, it's true. Yeah. Well, I would also like to call your. cookbook. You can eat this because this is true about your recipes and your cooking, Josh,
他也会对我们的孩子这么说。比如，他们会尝试一个食谱，你会说，伙计们，你们可以做这个。所以当需要给书命名时，我说，亲爱的，我们必须叫它《你可以做这个》，因为那是你一直对我们说的话。是的，是真的。是的。好吧，我也想叫你的食谱《你可以吃这个》，因为关于你的食谱和你的烹饪，乔什，这是真的，
is, for example, you have your one sheet fajitas. That is a family favorite of ours. Is that in the cookbook? Absolutely. Yay. Okay. And the spice mix on that, it's not too spicy for the kids, but it's still complex for the adults. So it's like mild but complex. And something that I think is true of all your cooking is you really can. I would tell my kids, you can eat this. Josh made it. That's so sweet. Okay, then I'll try it. And it got them to try new things. So you can make this and your kids can eat this. This is a cookbook for the whole family. And Josh, please tell me that you brought something in for us today. Oh, you know I did. Because I see a box next to you. You know I did. All right. So I brought in the granola.
比如，你有你的单盘法希塔。那是我们家最喜欢的。那在食谱里吗？绝对在。耶。好的，上面的香料混合，对孩子们来说不会太辣，但对成年人来说依然复杂。所以它既温和又复杂。我认为你所有烹饪的一个共同点是，你真的可以。我会告诉我的孩子们，你可以吃这个。乔什做的。这太甜了。好吧，那我会尝尝。这让他们尝试了新事物。所以你可以做这个，你的孩子们可以吃这个。这是一本适合全家人的食谱。乔什，请告诉我你今天带了什么给我们。哦，你知道我带了。因为我看到你旁边有个盒子。你知道我带了。好吧。所以我带了格兰诺拉麦片。
Josh's homemade granola. It's my favorite granola. If you love granola, y'all, this is for you. The recipe is in the cookbook. I spent years perfecting this granola recipe. And it's like I can say it's one of like it's one of the best recipes in the book. I'm a little surprised you included it in the cookbook. I said he shouldn't. I was like, babe, you need to sell this at the grocery story. I agree.
乔什的自制格兰诺拉麦片。这是我最喜欢的格兰诺拉麦片。如果你喜欢格兰诺拉麦片，伙计们，这是给你们的。食谱在食谱里。我花了好几年时间完善这个格兰诺拉麦片食谱。我可以说是书里最好的食谱之一。我有点惊讶你把它收录在食谱里了。我说他不应该。我说，亲爱的，你应该在杂货店卖这个。我同意。
But he wanted to share it. He wanted you guys to be able to make it too. I do. I do. I want it. And you know, I'll still make it for you too, you know. I know. I know.
但他想分享它。他想让你们也能做。我确实想。我确实想。而且你知道，我还是会为你做，你知道。我知道。我知道。
But we sort of joke that when we grow old, we're going to like live in some little town. and he's going to make granola, and we're going to put it in little brown paper bags and sell it at the corner little coffee shop. Yes, and you should also do like spice mixes. Yes, Josh's fajita spice mix, Josh's taco spice mix. You're good with the spices.
但我们开玩笑说，当我们老了，我们要住在某个小镇。他会做格兰诺拉麦片，我们会把它装在小棕色纸袋里，在街角的咖啡店卖。是的，你还应该做一些香料混合。是的，乔什的法希塔香料混合，乔什的塔可香料混合。你很擅长香料。
Thank you. Thank you so much. It's spicy and granola. It's your autobiography. And then lastly, you made cookies. Yeah. Oh, yay. And these were probably the first cookie
谢谢。非常感谢。香料和格兰诺拉麦片。这是你的自传。最后，你做了饼干。是的。哦，耶。这些可能是第一种饼干
that I actually, I think, perfected to, like where I was like, this is like, this is just a dang good cookie. And I'm super confident with it. So I brought one for Cassie and Sam too. Getting some cheers from the booth. Yay. Well, we're so happy to have you here. We're so excited for our cookbook.
我实际上，我想，完善到，就像我当时想，这就像，这简直是一块好得不得了的饼干。我对此非常有信心。所以我给卡西和萨姆也带了一块。从展位传来了一些欢呼声。耶。好吧，我们很高兴你能来。我们为我们的食谱感到非常兴奋。
You guys, go out and get it if you haven't. It's called You Can Make This. We really just made this with like a lot of love in our hearts. We hope you like it. Help Josh and Ange get on the bestseller list, y'all. Get this cookbook. All right. We will take a break, and when we come back, we're going to start talking about all the food on the office.
伙计们，如果你们还没买，就去买吧。它叫《你可以做这个》。我们真的是怀着很多爱制作了它。我们希望你们喜欢它。帮乔什和安吉登上畅销书榜单吧，伙计们。买这本食谱。好吧。我们要休息一下，回来后，我们将开始讨论《办公室》里的所有食物。
Yep. We are back. That was so fun for me. I know. He was really nervous. And I was like, Josh, it's just me and Jenna, you know? But he just wanted to do a good job. And he's so earnest, you know, as a person.
是的。我们回来了。这对我来说太有趣了。我知道。他真的很紧张。我当时说，乔什，这只是我和珍娜，你知道吗？但他只是想做好。而且他是一个非常真诚的人，你知道，作为一个个体。
I was so delighted to have him on the podcast. You guys are so cute together. All right. Well, I think it's time to dig into some of the most fun food moments, both on and offset of the office. Let's start with onset. Okay. You know, there are so many ways that food served as a plot point in episodes. Yeah.
我很高兴能请他上播客。你们在一起太可爱了。好吧。嗯，我想是时候深入探讨一些最有趣的食物时刻了，无论是在《办公室》的镜头前还是镜头后。让我们从镜头前开始。好的。你知道，食物在剧集中作为情节点的作用有很多种。
Like a lot. Starting with the pilot, with the stapler and jello. Oh, I actually looked up how many times we put things in jello. the show? Are you ready for this? Is it more than two? It is. Well, if you count a simulation, that's a hint. So you have Dwight's stapler, right? That's in the pilot. You have Michael's world's best boss mug. Also in the pilot. Also in the pilot. You have Andy's calculator in gay witch hunt. Oh, wow. I forgot about that. That's right. And then you have Dwight's rocket launcher in local ad. So remember in that episode, Dwight is playing that online game's second life.
是的。比如很多。从试播集开始，订书机和果冻。哦，我实际上查了一下我们在剧里把东西放进果冻里有多少次？你准备好了吗？超过两次吗？是的。好吧，如果你算上模拟，那是一个提示。所以你有德怀特的订书机，对吧？那是在试播集里。你有迈克尔的“世界最佳老板”马克杯。也在试播集里。也在试播集里。你有安迪在《同性恋搜捕》里的计算器。哦，哇。我忘了那个了。没错。然后你有德怀特在《本地广告》里的火箭发射器。所以记得在那一集中，德怀特在玩那个在线游戏《第二人生》。
Oh, yes. And Jim has a character in it too. And Dwight finds his rocket launcher in Jello. And then lastly, Dwight's phone in manager and salesman. Oh, yeah. So that was definitely a running food gag. Well, there are so many more. I was going down memory lane and I thought of just Michael's love of bacon, which then leads him to burning his foot. Classic. And then you know, there's those scenes that were deleted that have been added back to the superfan episode for the injury of all the food that Ryan brings Michael from the gas station.
哦，是的。吉姆在里面也有一个角色。德怀特在果冻里发现了他的火箭发射器。最后，德怀特在《经理与推销员》里的手机。哦，是的。所以那绝对是一个贯穿始终的食物梗。好吧，还有更多。我正在回忆往事，我想到了迈克尔对培根的热爱，这导致他烫伤了脚。经典。然后你知道，那些被删除的场景，已经被添加回了超级粉丝剧集中，关于瑞恩从加油站给迈克尔带的所有食物。
It's pretty incredible. And then I thought of the peanut butter that Dwight has to put in Michael's hair to get the gum out or the store-bought potato salad that Michael brings to David Wallace's party. How about Phyllis's microwave popcorn that interrupts the finer things club meeting. So good. These are all ways that food is used as a plot point. I mean, Kevin's chili, Angela's brownies, Andy making cherries jubilee. And of course, Ryan's cheese pita that started the fire. There are so many. But I think maybe my favorite food plot line is the one that led us
这真是太不可思议了。然后我想到了德怀特为了把口香糖弄掉，不得不往迈克尔头发上抹花生酱，还有迈克尔带到大卫·华莱士派对上的那种超市买的土豆沙拉。还有菲利斯在“精致生活俱乐部”会议期间微波炉加热的爆米花。太棒了。这些都是食物作为剧情点的方式。我是说，凯文的辣椒，安吉拉的布朗尼，安迪做的樱桃朱比利。当然，还有瑞安那盘引发火灾的奶酪皮塔饼。这样的例子太多了。但我认为我最喜欢的食物剧情线可能是那条让我们
to meet Sconesy cider. Sconesy cider. And you know, lady, I went to the superfan episode for christening when I was prepping this episode of all about food, I was just hoping there was more sconesy cider. There's not. That's it. You get what you get. You get what you get. Well, I was thinking about, too, just all of the Christmas parties, all the parties, the food. Yeah. So much. And then, of course, there are all the things that we actually had to eat, like Meredith's ice cream cake, pretzels on pretzel day, Nellie had to eat all those tacos, Kevin ate a stock of raw broccoli, Creed's mung beans, creeds raw potato, Michael's mayo and olives, Michael's Fetuccini Alfredo, ugh, and fun run, Dwight eating a hard-boiled egg that made everyone sick, and then of course
遇见斯康西·赛德（Sconesy Cider）的那条。斯康西·赛德。你知道吗，女士，我在准备这期关于食物的剧集时，去看了《洗礼》那集的超级粉丝版，我当时只是希望里面有更多斯康西·赛德的镜头。结果没有。就那样了。你得到什么就是什么。你得到什么就是什么。嗯，我也在想，所有的圣诞派对，所有的派对，还有那些食物。是的。太多了。当然，还有所有我们真正必须吃下去的东西，比如梅雷迪斯的冰淇淋蛋糕，椒盐卷饼日的椒盐卷饼，内莉必须吃掉的所有那些塔可，凯文吃了一整株生西兰花，克里德的绿豆，克里德的生土豆，迈克尔的蛋黄酱和橄榄，迈克尔的奶油培根意面，呃，还有趣味跑，德怀特吃了一个让所有人都恶心的水煮蛋，然后当然
we all got to eat pie in work bus. Oh, yeah, that pie was so good. Yeah, I was thinking back to some of my favorite office food scenes, and the pie is definitely one of them. Like, I'll never forget that pie. I'll never forget that pie because of what we went through to get it. I know. But you know what else? I'll never forget is the grilled cheese on the roof, Jim and Pam's grilled cheese date. It was so good. You've talked about that grilled cheese. I know. I feel like you're chasing that one particular grilled cheese. Have you ever had anything come close to it? That's a good question. Like since? Yeah. Have I had a grilled cheese like that grilled cheese? I don't know if I have. I'm going to tell you one my mom made. That was so good. She had her skillet. She put a little pat of butter in there.
我们都在工作巴士上吃了派。哦，是的，那个派太好吃了。是的，我回想了一下我最喜欢的《办公室》食物场景，那个派绝对是其中之一。就像，我永远不会忘记那个派。我永远不会忘记那个派，因为我们为了得到它经历了那么多。我知道。但你知道还有什么吗？我永远不会忘记屋顶上的烤奶酪三明治，吉姆和帕姆的烤奶酪约会。那太棒了。你提到过那个烤奶酪三明治。我知道。我觉得你一直在寻找那种特定的烤奶酪三明治。你有没有吃过接近那个味道的东西？这是个好问题。比如在那之后？是的。我吃过像那个烤奶酪三明治一样的吗？我不知道我有没有。我要告诉你一个我妈妈做的。那太好吃了。她用她的平底锅。她放了一小块黄油进去。
She got that thick Texas toast and just like American cheddar cheese. And she made me a grilled cheese and that bread got a little crispy and crunchy. And then the cheese was gooey. And she did it in the skillet. You know, my son has a friend. And whenever he goes to this friend's house, the mom makes some grilled cheese. And it kind of sounds like that. And I'm going to shout her out, Stephanie, I'm talking about your grilled cheese on office ladies because it is legend in our house. Like Stephanie's grilled cheese is to my son, what Jim and Pam. rooftop grilled cheeses. I wonder who made it for you that day. I'd love to know. It might have just been Phil Shea. Probably. I mean, yeah. He would whip up stuff for us. Yeah, for those scenes.
她拿了那种厚厚的德州吐司，还有美式切达干酪。她给我做了一个烤奶酪三明治，面包变得又脆又酥。然后奶酪变得黏糊糊的。她是在平底锅里做的。你知道，我儿子有个朋友。每当他去这个朋友家，那位妈妈就会做烤奶酪三明治。听起来有点像那个。我要特别提一下她，斯蒂芬妮，我在《办公室女士》里提到你的烤奶酪三明治，因为它在我们家是传奇。就像斯蒂芬妮的烤奶酪三明治对我儿子来说，就像吉姆和帕姆的屋顶烤奶酪三明治一样。我想知道那天是谁为你做的。我很想知道。可能只是菲尔·谢伊（Phil Shea）。很可能。我是说，是的。他会为我们现做那些东西。是的，为了那些场景。
Because I know that Phil Shea made the French toast that I ate in Dream Team at Michael's condo, and it was likewise delicious. Phil Shea made me peanut butter and jelly sandwiches. When I would have to eat something in the background and I needed a sandwich, he would make me the best dang PBJ. What was so good about it? You know, I feel like it was the bread. He just got great bread. Yeah. Was it like white bread or wheat bread? Was it like a thicker bread? Describe it to me. He asked me. You guys, this is turning into like, sorry. This is like food porn episode. Sorry. But tell me, please. He listed all the breads I could possibly want. And I was like, Phil, I just like, you know, a basic white bread. And the one he got, I don't know what it was.
因为我知道菲尔·谢伊做了我在《梦之队》里在迈克尔公寓吃的法式吐司，同样非常美味。菲尔·谢伊给我做过花生酱果酱三明治。当我在背景里必须吃点什么，而我需要一个三明治时，他会给我做最好吃的花生酱果酱三明治。它有什么特别好吃的？你知道，我觉得是面包。他总是能弄到很棒的面包。是的。是白面包还是全麦面包？是那种厚一点的面包吗？描述给我听听。他问我。你们这些家伙，这快变成，抱歉。这就像是食物色情片剧集。抱歉。但请告诉我。他列出了我可能想要的所有面包。我说，菲尔，我只是，你知道，普通的白面包。他拿来的那个，我不知道是什么。
It was like kind of squishy a little, you know? Not damp squishy, like the good, bouncy, bouncy. And it was so yummy. You know what one of my other favorite onset food memories is, is the cheese puffs. Were they good? No, I'm sorry. I should say it's what the cheese puffs brought to my life. It was a lot of fun.
它有点软绵绵的，你知道吗？不是那种潮湿的软，而是那种好的、有弹性的、Q弹的。它太好吃了。你知道我另一个最喜欢的片场食物记忆是什么吗？是奶酪泡芙。它们好吃吗？不，抱歉。我应该说的是奶酪泡芙给我的生活带来了什么。那真的很有趣。
They were kind of stale. Stale, and I think you guys, like, everything was stained orange. Like your fingertips. Yeah. But we had so much fun shooting that. Well, I have a question for you, Angela. Did you ever have, like, a scene where you had to eat something that you hated? It wasn't so much that I hated.
它们有点受潮了。受潮了，而且我想你们，就像，所有东西都被染成了橙色。比如你的指尖。是的。但我们在拍摄那个场景时玩得很开心。好吧，我有个问题要问你，安吉拉。你有没有过那种必须吃掉你讨厌的东西的场景？与其说是我讨厌。
It's when it turned on me. Okay, here's the thing. I've talked about this before, but when we have that ice cream cake in the Alliance for Meredith's birthday, who didn't even want dairy, we started filming that at 7 a.m. 7 a.m. someone hands you a plate of a big slice of ice cream cake. You haven't eaten anything else because you're not a breakfast person. So the first thing you eat is a big honkin piece of ice cream cake. And then you eat that piece of cake for three more hours. Yeah. And by the end of it, you don't ever want another piece of ice cream cake again in your life. I mean, for years, lady, for years I could not eat like ice cream, anything like ice cream related after that. episode. It really turned on me. They had to get me a bucket. Oh, lady, same. Yeah. Same. That was really tough. And then, do you remember, I was trying to figure out the episode where the party planning committee, I think it was a Christmas episode, where they had all the chocolates and
不如说是它让我反胃。好吧，是这样的。我以前说过，但当我们拍摄《联盟》里梅雷迪斯生日的那场戏，吃那个冰淇淋蛋糕时，她甚至都不想要乳制品，我们早上7点就开始拍了。早上7点，有人递给你一盘一大块冰淇淋蛋糕。你没吃过别的东西，因为你不是个吃早餐的人。所以你吃的第一样东西就是一大块冰淇淋蛋糕。然后你还要吃那块蛋糕三个小时。是的。到最后，你这辈子都不想再吃第二块冰淇淋蛋糕了。我是说，好几年，女士，好几年我都不能吃像冰淇淋相关的东西了。那集之后。它真的让我反胃了。他们不得不给我拿个桶。哦，女士，我也是。是的。我也是。那真的很艰难。然后，你还记得吗，我一直在想那个派对策划委员会的剧集，我想是圣诞那一集，他们有所有的巧克力和
chocolate boxes. Oh, yeah. And Ed Helms and Mindy, who were notorious for eating prop food, started digging into the chocolates and one had maggots in it. Oh, yes, I remember this. because they did not intend for us to eat them. Yes, it was supposed to be set decoration. And Mindy and Ed started going into them. I thought, oh, my God, we freaked out. We're like, ah, oh, it was so disgusting. Well, now that's bringing up a memory for me
巧克力盒。哦，是的。埃德·赫尔姆斯和敏迪，他们以吃道具食物闻名，开始挖巧克力吃，结果里面有一个有蛆。哦，是的，我记得这个。因为他们没打算让我们吃那些。是的，那本来应该是场景装饰。敏迪和埃德开始吃起来了。我想，哦，天哪，我们吓坏了。我们就像，啊，哦，太恶心了。好吧，现在这勾起了我的一个记忆
where I can't remember what it was. I feel like, because it was me and BJ, BJ also loved to eat prop food. And there was like a big buffet of food. Gosh, it might have been... Was it Diwali? No, no, no. It was in the conference room.
我不记得是什么了。我觉得，因为当时是我和BJ，BJ也喜欢吃道具食物。然后那里有一个大自助餐。天哪，可能是……是排灯节那一集吗？不，不，不。是在会议室里。
Oh, I wish I could remember, but it was a conference room scene and there's tons of food, but like the storyline is that we're actually not wanting to eat it. I can't remember why, what this is. Someone out there is probably like shouting it out right now. But because that food was going to stay out for a long period of time, they had kind of sprayed something on it to keep it safe like under the lights so it wouldn't get super nasty and smell, but you're not supposed to eat it. And BJ and I, like, between takes, we were, like, picking at the buffet, and they had to run over and be like, no, no, no, no, do not
哦，我真希望我能想起来，但那是一个会议室的场景，有很多食物，但剧情是我们其实不想吃它。我不记得为什么，这是什么了。外面的人现在可能正在大声喊出来。但因为那些食物要放很长时间，他们往上面喷了点东西来保持安全，比如在灯光下，这样它就不会变得超级恶心和发臭，但你是不应该吃它的。我和BJ，在拍摄间隙，我们一直在挑自助餐吃，他们不得不跑过来，说，不，不，不，不，不要
eat that. That is, it's not even prop food. It's, like, decorative food. Yeah. They're like, don't eat the decorative food. And they had shalacked it with something. Yes, which is, like, what those chocolates were. Those were, like, decoration. Yeah. Yeah. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. Well, I feel like, for the most part, I was really spared from having to eat anything gross. Like, I think about you guys and those hot dogs on beach games. My character is a vegetarian when she needed to be. I mean, we've discussed that. Sometimes she is.
吃那个。那是，那甚至不是道具食物。那是，装饰性食物。是的。他们说，不要吃装饰性食物。而且他们用某种东西给它上了漆。是的，就像那些巧克力一样。那些是，装饰品。是的。是的。嗯。嗯。好吧，我觉得，在很大程度上，我真的免于吃任何恶心的东西。比如，我想到你们在《海滩游戏》里吃的那些热狗。我的角色在需要的时候是个素食主义者。我是说，我们讨论过那个。有时她是。
Sometimes she isn't. But so I did not eat the hot dogs. I didn't either because I was taking my diligent notes. Yeah, but a bunch of people did and they got real grossed out. I remember when it turned on them. Mm-hmm. a hot dog turning on you? Outside, and it was hot out there, eating all those hot dogs on the hot sun. Well, one of the people who had to do the most eating on our show was Rain Wilson.
有时她不是。但我没有吃那些热狗。我也没有，因为我在做勤奋的笔记。是的，但很多人吃了，他们真的觉得很恶心。我记得当它让他们反胃的时候。嗯。热狗让你反胃？在外面，外面很热，在烈日下吃那么多热狗。好吧，我们剧组里吃得最多的人之一是雷恩·威尔逊。
Wait, can I just stop you right there? What is it? Had to do a lot of eating or chose to do a lot of eating. Both. I think both. Definitely both. Because when he commits, he goes all out, and he didn't have to eat as much as he did. Well, before I left town, I had lunch with Rain. And after our lunch, We sat in my car, and he shared his on-and-offset food memories with me. It was really sweet. I want you guys to hear it. Okay. Hey, office ladies, people, listeners.
等等，我能打断你一下吗？是什么？是不得不吃很多，还是选择吃很多。两者都有。我想两者都有。绝对两者都有。因为当他投入时，他会全力以赴，而且他其实不必吃那么多。好吧，在我离开城里之前，我和雷恩吃了午饭。午饭后，我们坐在我的车里，他和我分享了他片场内外的食物记忆。真的很贴心。我想让你们听听。好的。嘿，办公室女士们，各位，听众们。
This is Rain. Hi, Rain. It's Jenna. Jenna Fisher. I'm with you. We just had lunch. And Jenna brought her sound recording equipment, this very fancy taskcom recorder with lots of fancy cables and a big mic attached to it and then she forgot to put a like i guess the
这是雷恩。嗨，雷恩。我是珍娜。珍娜·费舍尔。我和你在一起。我们刚吃了午饭。珍娜带了她的录音设备，这个非常高级的塔斯肯（Tascam）录音机，带有很多高级线缆和一个大麦克风，然后她忘了放一个，我想是
sim card thing in it the card in it so we're recording it on my phone and this is yes well we just ate food and i said we're doing an episode about office food and you have some good stories because you had the very unique position of having both insane food storylines written for you where you had to eat crazy things, but then also you made some choices that you maybe had to deal with. But first of all, I want to say that you had breakfast for lunch today. I did, yeah. Yeah, so we had lunch, and then Jenna had the avocado toast with poached eggs and bacon. I wanted both eggs and bacon on my avocado toast at 1.30 p.m.
SIM卡之类的东西在里面，卡在里面，所以我们用我的手机录音，这是，是的，好吧，我们刚吃了东西，我说我们要拍一集关于办公室食物的节目，你有一些好的故事，因为你有一个非常独特的处境，既有为你写的疯狂的食物剧情，你不得不吃疯狂的东西，但同时你也做了一些你可能不得不处理的选择。但首先，我想说你今天午餐吃了早餐。我吃了，是的。是的，所以我们吃了午饭，然后珍娜吃了牛油果吐司配水波蛋和培根。我在下午1点半的时候想在我的牛油果吐司上同时加蛋和培根。
She went for it, and it was glorious to see. I love a woman. with that appetite. Yes, I've never denied my appetite. I can't do it. I like it. Too much. And Dwight has his appetites. Yes, he certainly does.
她真的吃了，看到这一幕真是太棒了。我喜欢有那种胃口的女人。是的，我从不否认我的胃口。我做不到。我喜欢它。太多了。德怀特也有他的胃口。是的，他当然有。
Yeah, no, your question was right on because here's the thing. One of the thing that really bugs me about actors is when you're watching a movie and you can see that the actors aren't really eating in a meal scene, they're like pushing the food around on their plates. They're pushing the peas around or whatever. Because, you know, when you're shooting a scene, you have to shoot. like 12 different takes and lots of different versions and you know and I get it people don't want to like be eating enormous mouthfuls of food uh because you if you do 12 takes then that's you know
是的，不，你的问题问得很对，因为是这样的。关于演员，有一件事真的很困扰我，那就是当你在看电影时，你可以看出演员在吃饭的场景里并没有真正吃，他们只是在盘子里推来推去。他们在推豌豆什么的。因为，你知道，当你拍摄一个场景时，你必须拍12个不同的镜头和很多不同的版本，你知道，我明白，人们不想吃一大口一大口的食物，呃，因为如果你拍12个镜头，那就是，你知道
12 times however many mouthfuls of food but that's one thing that's always bugged me so I've always kind of as an actor prided myself on like committing to eating well I appreciate it I mean how fun is it to watch all of those great actors and like good fellows and the godfellows and the god father just like devour, devour their big Italian meals and their steak. Like, it's so satisfying to watch. Yeah, yeah. And they were always trying to think of ways to have Dwight eating because I think they saw that I fully committed kind of ravenously to the enterprise.
12次，不管多少口食物，但那是一直困扰我的一件事，所以我作为一个演员，一直以投入地吃东西为荣。我很欣赏这一点。我是说，看那些伟大的演员，比如《好家伙》、《教父》里的人大口大口地吃他们的意大利大餐和牛排，是多么有趣。看起来，看的时候太满足了。是的，是的。他们总是想方设法让德怀特吃东西，因为我想他们看出我完全投入到了这项事业中，有点贪婪地。
I think my favorite food memory was the breakfast that I had with Jan when I was planning to, the Crentist episode, when I was planning to overthrow Michael. And I had pancakes and eggs and toast and waffles and then I cover the whole thing with syrup. Now, that was your choice. That was not in the script that you covered it all with syrup for a long time, right? Or was it? We don't remember. I think it was in the script.
我想我最喜欢的食物记忆是我和简在计划时吃的早餐，就是《牙医》那一集，当我计划推翻迈克尔时。我吃了煎饼、鸡蛋、吐司和华夫饼，然后我在整个东西上浇满了糖浆。现在，那是你的选择。剧本里并没有写你浇了那么久的糖浆，对吧？还是写了？我们不记得了。我想剧本里写了。
And I remember Paul Lieberstein talking to me about it, about the idea of like locking eyes with her and then just pouring syrup for far too long. but I don't think he insisted that I eat as much as I actually ate in the course of the scene and I did dig in to those pancakes. I'll never forget that flavor and I'm so glad I did. It was so much, it was so much fun and I think Malora, I think it kind of blew her mind exactly how many pounds of pancakes I ate during that scene. But what about the scene where Dwight is eating all?
我记得保罗·利伯斯坦和我谈过这件事，关于那种和她对视，然后倒糖浆倒得太久的想法。但我认为他并没有坚持让我吃掉我在场景中实际吃的那么多，但我确实大口吃下了那些煎饼。我永远不会忘记那个味道，我很高兴我这么做了。那太多了，太有趣了，我想马洛拉，我想她被我在那个场景中吃了多少磅煎饼给惊呆了。但是德怀特吃掉所有东西的那个场景呢？
all of his, like, about to spoil food, all of his... Right, from, like, the fallout shelter or his survival shelter. Yeah, there were big cans, and I think they were supposed to be canned beets or something, but I think they put peaches in them. I just remember I was eating, like, syrupy canned goods. Okay. But, again, I ate a lot of syrupy canned goods. And one of my favorite Dwight lines is, like, I'm ravenous after a night of lovemaking.
他所有的，比如，快要变质的食物，他所有的……对，从，比如，防空洞或他的生存避难所里拿出来的。是的，有大罐头，我想它们应该是罐装甜菜什么的，但我想他们放了桃子在里面。我只记得我在吃，像，糖浆罐头食品。好的。但是，再一次，我吃了很多糖浆罐头食品。我最喜欢的德怀特台词之一是，比如，我在一夜缠绵后饿极了。
I forget what was on the table. I think in the scene you don't really see what I was eating, but I was just pounding French fries and hamburgers, and I don't even know what. But I love that about Dwight's character that he did not shirk committing to having full plates of food. And then what about offset? Did you have a breakfast order from Sergio? Did you have a go-to breakfast? Did you eat breakfast in the morning? Would you order breakfast?
我忘了桌上有什么了。我想在那个场景里你并没有真正看到我在吃什么，但我只是在狂吃炸薯条和汉堡，我甚至不知道是什么。但我喜欢德怀特角色的这一点，他从不回避投入地吃满盘的食物。那么片场外呢？你从塞尔吉奥那里订过早餐吗？你有固定的早餐吗？你早上吃早餐吗？你会订早餐吗？
Oh, yeah. I had breakfast. Sergio, in his food truck, they were just otherworldly. They were magnificent. The food we got on the office set was, it was kind of ridiculous. The food that is on the set of a successful TV show, like season one of a TV show, it's kind of like some old tuna sandwiches and some hard-boiled eggs and stuff like that. But then when you get to like season four or five and it's really profitable, like it's lobster rolls.
哦，是的。我吃早餐。塞尔吉奥，在他的餐车里，它们简直是超凡脱俗。它们太棒了。我们在《办公室》片场得到的食物，有点荒谬。在一部成功的电视剧片场，比如电视剧的第一季，它有点像一些旧的金枪鱼三明治和一些水煮蛋之类的东西。但当你到了第四或第五季，它真的很赚钱时，比如就是龙虾卷了。
And all I know is it involved turkey bacon, black beans, avocado. Yeah, I think that was it. And some eggs. I don't remember how I had the eggs. But I remember I really, truly, over the course of that show, I ate a hell a lot of turkey bacon. I ate a lot of turkey bacon. It's where I discovered turkey bacon. Right.
我只知道它包括火鸡培根、黑豆、牛油果。是的，我想就是那个。还有一些鸡蛋。我不记得我是怎么吃鸡蛋的。但我记得我真的，确实，在那部剧的过程中，我吃了很多火鸡培根。我吃了很多火鸡培根。那是我发现火鸡培根的地方。对。
I don't know who ordered it first. But it was so good. It's almost as good as bacon. And that's how they should advertise it. I had real bacon today. It looked good. It was good. Did you offer me any of your real bacon?
我不知道是谁先订的。但它太好吃了。它几乎和培根一样好吃。这就是他们应该宣传它的方式。我今天吃了真正的培根。看起来不错。很好吃。你给我分一点你的真培根了吗？
No. Nope. Not even one bite. Not even one nibble. Well, thank you, Rain. I had a salad because I'm chubby and I need to be... Rayne, Wilson, you are not chubby. I'm a chubby guy.
没有。没有。连一口都没有。连一点点都没有。好吧，谢谢你，雷恩。我吃了一个沙拉，因为我很胖，我需要……雷恩·威尔逊，你一点也不胖。我是个胖家伙。
It's okay. I'm a middle-aged man, and this is the cross that I've been. Your metabolism is slowing. It's just age where it's happening to all of us. It's, yeah, yeah, yeah. Nothing we can do. All right, good luck with the episode. Love you, Jenna. Love you. That was so fun. You guys were just in your car. In the back of my car. What if like someone, I mean, that's the paparazzi moment that didn't happen, where it's like you and Rain in the back seat of your car. We're just talking in a microphone. That's awesome. Well, what's funny about that, Amherst.
没关系。我是个中年男人，这就是我背负的十字架。你的新陈代谢在变慢。这只是年龄问题，我们所有人都会经历。是的，是的，是的。我们无能为力。好吧，祝这集节目顺利。爱你，珍娜。爱你。那太有趣了。你们俩就在车里。在我的车后座。如果有人，我是说，那是没发生的狗仔队时刻，就是你和雷恩在你的车后座。我们只是对着麦克风说话。那太棒了。好吧，关于那个，阿默斯特，有趣的是什么。
Angela, is that I recorded that with him, like, two days before that crazy, like, jumbo-tron cold play moment. Yes. And then did you see, after that happened, people started sending me pictures where they had made it into Pam and Dwight. And I was like, oh, my gosh, Rain and I were just in the back of a car two days ago. I'm telling you, people went off because they made so many. whatever, meme things.
安吉拉，是我在那个疯狂的、像酷玩乐队大屏幕时刻的前两天和他录的。是的，然后你看到了吗，那件事发生后，人们开始给我发图片，他们把图片做成了帕姆和德怀特。我说，哦，天哪，雷恩和我两天前才在车后座。我告诉你，人们疯了，因为他们做了太多。什么的，表情包之类的东西。
Yeah. I mean, there's the one where, you know, when Phyllis discovers Dwight and Angela. Yes, I saw that one. Did you see the Game of Thrones one with the Lannister, brother and sister? Yes. There was a lot. Oh, and you know what? Speaking of Rain's share about breakfast, I'm pretty sure the turkey bacon started with Rashida.
是的。我是说，有一个，你知道，当菲利斯发现德怀特和安吉拉的时候。是的，我看到了那个。你看到那个《权力的游戏》里兰尼斯特兄妹的了吗？是的。有很多。哦，你知道吗？说到雷恩分享的早餐，我很确定火鸡培根是从拉什达开始的。
Oh, see, that's funny because I thought maybe it started with John. That's where I got the idea. But we had similar call times, and I saw it on his. plate and I was like, oh, I want that. Well, that would make sense. Yeah. Well, I don't know, lady, because you would be in at the same time as Rashida in the mornings. Yes. So maybe Rashida started it. It was either Rashida or John. Okay. Well, we got to the bottom of that. Wow, we're good. Here's the thing. When Rain was talking, though, about our food and how lucky we were, I couldn't help but think of my dad. And the time he came to set and my sisters asked him,
哦，看，那很有趣，因为我以为可能是从约翰开始的。我就是从他那里得到的想法。但我们有相似的通告时间，我在他的盘子里看到了，我说，哦，我想要那个。好吧，那说得通。是的。好吧，我不知道，女士，因为你早上和拉什达的时间是一样的。是的。所以也许是拉什达开始的。要么是拉什达，要么是约翰。好吧，我们弄清楚了。哇，我们真棒。是这样的。不过，当雷恩谈到我们的食物以及我们有多幸运时，我不禁想到了我的父亲。还有他来片场的那次，我姐妹们问他，
what was it like being on the set of the office? All he could talk about was the food. It was kind of legendary, which is why we're doing a whole episode about it today. Well, you guys, I reached out to Creed Bratton and asked him his memories about food on the set. And here's what he had to say. Yes, there was the scene where everyone was throwing up in the office and I was eating a bowl of noodles. I believe with chopsticks and just enjoying the whole process
在《办公室》片场是什么感觉？他一直在谈论食物。这简直成了传奇，这就是为什么我们今天要做一整集关于它的节目。好吧，伙计们，我联系了克里德·布拉顿，问了他对片场食物的记忆。这是他说的。是的，有一场戏是每个人都在办公室里呕吐，而我正在吃一碗面条。我想是用筷子吃的，而且很享受整个过程。
but didn't make me sick at all. Sergio, yeah, Sergio was great. Toward the end, I basically ate at lunch just a piece of chicken and some broccoli. In the morning, I'd have egg whites and sausage and a piece of toast. I think John was a big fan of just the chicken and the broccoli, too. You'd have to ask him.
但这并没有让我感到恶心。塞尔吉奥，是的，塞尔吉奥太棒了。到最后，我午餐基本上只吃一块鸡肉和一些西兰花。早上，我会吃蛋白、香肠和一片吐司。我想约翰也是鸡肉和西兰花的忠实粉丝。你得去问他。
But I recall a few times noticing that he was eating the same thing. And a dueling chicken, as it were. All right, love you, girls. Bye. That's very funny. John would put broccoli in his egg whites in the morning, and it was stinky. So stinky. He would stink up the whole trailer.
但我记得有几次注意到他吃的是一样的东西。可以说是“决斗鸡”。好了，爱你们，女孩们。再见。那太搞笑了。约翰早上会在蛋白里放西兰花，而且很臭。非常臭。他会把整个拖车弄得臭气熏天。
Yeah. But this is also reminding me. of all the egg whites people ate. Like people, we had a big, like, egg white trend in the mornings. What did they do with all the yolks? Where'd all the egg yolks go? I don't know. Did we just have a giant bucket of yolks?
是的。但这也让我想起了大家吃的那些蛋白。就像大家一样，我们早上有一股巨大的“蛋白风潮”。他们怎么处理所有的蛋黄？所有的蛋黄都去哪了？我不知道。我们是不是有一个巨大的蛋黄桶？
I don't know. We should ask Sergio that. I wish we would have asked him. I know. What do you do with all the yolks? What do you do with all the yolks? Well, you know, spoiler alert, we already spoke to Sergio
我不知道。我们应该问问塞尔吉奥。我真希望我们问过他。我知道。你拿那些蛋黄怎么办？你拿那些蛋黄怎么办？好吧，你知道，剧透预警，我们已经和塞尔吉奥谈过了。
and we failed to ask him about the yolks. Maybe next time. Next time. Well, you know, Creed's. favorite food memory from his time on the office. The noodles? Is the noodles one. And he's talking about that famous barfing scene in Niagara, you know?
但我们没问他关于蛋黄的事。也许下次吧。下次。好吧，你知道，克里德在《办公室》期间最喜欢的食物记忆是什么吗？面条？是面条那次。他说的就是《尼亚加拉》里那场著名的呕吐戏，你知道吗？
But lady, did you know that that scene has a name online? What's it called? The boiled egg vomiting chain. What? Isn't that so funny? Yes. Yeah. But I love that Creed shared that one, and that's the one that stood out to him.
但是莱迪，你知道那场戏在网上有个名字吗？叫什么？“煮鸡蛋呕吐链”。什么？那不是很有趣吗？是的。是的，但我很高兴克里德分享了那个，那是他印象最深的一个。
So we've got something fun coming up next in this food episode. It's the real gym that I found in the bonus content. For those of you that have the DVDs, it is Dis 2, Season 3. Lady, do you want to guess who had a cooking show at Dundra Mifflin? Or who tried to have a cooking show? If I had to guess, I would say maybe Michael. Good guess. Or maybe Kevin.
所以我们在这一集美食节目中还有一些有趣的内容。这是我在奖励内容中发现的真正瑰宝。对于那些有DVD的人来说，它是第三季的第二碟。莱迪，你想猜猜谁在邓德 Mifflin 有个烹饪节目吗？或者谁尝试过做烹饪节目？如果让我猜，我会说是迈克尔。猜得好。或者可能是凯文。
Ding, ding, ding, ding. Kevin. It is Kevin. Are you ready for the name of his cooking show? Okay. It's simple. It's to the point. His show is called Kevin Cooks Stuff.
叮，叮，叮，叮。凯文。就是凯文。你准备好听他的烹饪节目名字了吗？好的。很简单。直截了当。他的节目叫《凯文做饭》。
Okay. I'm watching that show. I'm dying to know what he cooked. So this whole bit is about five minutes. I'm going to share a little bit of it. It starts in the kitchen, and he keeps getting interrupted. Let's hear it. Welcome to Kevin Cook Stuff in the office.
好的。我要看那个节目。我太想知道他做了什么了。所以这一整段大约五分钟。我要分享其中的一小部分。它从厨房开始，他一直被打断。让我们听听。欢迎来到《办公室》里的《凯文做饭》。
Yes. I am your host, Kevin. Okay. So sometimes my fiance, Stacey, she forgets to pack me lunch. What do I do? I have to cook things in the office. And trust me, it is not as bad as it... Hey, what? I'm doing my cooking show thingy. And I'm going to the bathroom. Okay. So this is our main cooking area. We have a toaster. And I'm going to the bathroom. And... and a microwave. We used to have a blender as well, but we're pretty sure that Meredith stole it. And hey, Stanley, what am I supposed to do? You're supposed to wait until I'm finished.
是的。我是你们的主持人，凯文。好的。所以有时候我的未婚妻斯泰西会忘记给我带午餐。我该怎么办？我必须在办公室里做饭。相信我，这并不像它……嘿，什么？我正在做我的烹饪节目呢。我要去洗手间。好的。所以这是我们的主要烹饪区。我们有一个烤面包机。我要去洗手间。还有……还有一个微波炉。我们以前还有一个搅拌机，但我们很确定是梅雷迪思偷走了它。嘿，斯坦利，我该怎么办？你应该等我做完。
I don't think so. Did you wash your hand, Stanley? I bet you didn't. Okay, we will gather ingredients at the vending machines, or as I like to call them, the supermarket that only takes quarters. Okay. So now he goes to the break room, to the supermarket. Yes. And he is going to gather ingredients to make some recipes.
我不这么认为。你洗手了吗，斯坦利？我敢打赌你没有。好的，我们会在自动售货机收集食材，或者像我喜欢称呼它们的那样，“只收25美分的超市”。好的。所以现在他去了休息室，去了超市。是的。他要收集食材来做一些食谱。
Out of stuff from the vending machine? Yeah. Casidias and cram brule. Lady, I brought in stuff to make Kevin's cassidias. You're going to hear the recipe. Okay. Okay. We're going to make it on our break. What is it? Well, I just want to eat Josh's granola. Well, sorry, you're also going to have Kevin's cassidias. Let's hear how he makes them. First, for the cassidias.
用自动售货机里的东西？是的。墨西哥馅饼和焦糖布丁。莱迪，我带了做凯文墨西哥馅饼的东西。你会听到食谱的。好的。好的。我们要休息时做。那是什么？好吧，我只是想吃乔什的格兰诺拉麦片。好吧，抱歉，你也要吃凯文的墨西哥馅饼。让我们听听他是怎么做的。首先，做墨西哥馅饼。
All you need is chips and squeezy cheese. This, I usually, I keep in my desk drawer, so nobody steals it. It's very important that you get a lot of cheese on there. You can make designs, if you wish, circles, flowers, and then you take another chip and bam. Casidia a la Kevin. Take the plate and you put it in the microwave for 10 to 15 seconds
你只需要薯片和挤压奶酪。这个，我通常放在我的办公桌抽屉里，这样没人会偷它。一定要在上面放很多奶酪，这一点非常重要。如果你愿意，你可以做成图案，圆圈、花朵，然后你拿另一片薯片，砰。凯文风味墨西哥馅饼。把盘子放进微波炉里加热10到15秒。
and take them out when they look melty. Oh, hot, hot, hot, I was so good. Oh my gosh, he ate it? Yes. In real time. Yes. So Brian, as Kevin ate it. I mean, there's no cutaway.
当它们看起来融化时就把它们拿出来。哦，烫，烫，烫，我太棒了。天哪，他真的吃了？是的。实时直播。是的。所以布莱恩，当凯文吃的时候。我的意思是，没有切镜头。
You, I was fine. I used to eat cheese whiz on top of trisketes. This was like one of my go-to college snacks. Yeah. Like I couldn't get enough of it. I've never heated it. Well, I brought them and we're going to try it. Oh, dear God. So I got just sort of like the big waffle chip and then I got cheese whiz and we're going to put it in the microwave. But we're not going to do it on Mike. But we are going to try it. We have to try it. All right. Well, next up is Kevin's dessert. As he said, he's going to make cream broulet. what he does is he takes a pudding, and it's in like a metal can. Uh-huh. And then he opens that. Metal? Yeah.
你，我没事。我以前常在饼干上涂奶酪酱。这就像我大学时的首选零食之一。是的。就像我怎么吃都不够。我从来没加热过它。好吧，我带了它们，我们要尝尝。哦，天哪。所以我拿了那种大华夫饼干，然后我拿了奶酪酱，我们要把它放进微波炉。但我们不会在麦克风前做。但我们要尝尝。我们必须尝尝。好了。接下来是凯文的甜点。正如他所说，他要做焦糖布丁。他做的是拿一个布丁，装在一个金属罐里。嗯哼。然后他打开那个。金属？是的。
Oh. It's like in a metal can. I don't know. He said it's pudding in a can. I've never seen it in a can. Okay, go ahead. And then he opens a bunch of sugar packets, and he just dumps them all on top of that pudding. Okay.
哦。它就像在一个金属罐里。我不知道。他说那是罐装布丁。我从来没见过罐装的。好的，继续。然后他打开一堆糖包，直接把它们全部倒在布丁上面。好的。
Then he's very careful to tell you to take the label off the metal can because then you're going to put the metal can. in the toaster oven and let it bake. And he says he's going to leave it there for a bit and he'll check back in. And then he goes over to his desk in accounting. So we've already learned that he keeps cheese whiz like in his desk drawer. Okay. But lady, you know that cabinet that's next to Kevin's desk.
然后他非常小心地告诉你把金属罐上的标签撕掉，因为接下来你要把金属罐放进烤箱里烤。他说他会把它放在那里一会儿，然后再回来检查。然后他走到会计部的办公桌前。所以我们已经知道他把奶酪酱放在办公桌抽屉里了。好的。但是莱迪，你知道凯文办公桌旁边的那个柜子吗。
So like if you're Kevin sitting at the desk to the left of you by the window, there's always been a big cabinet there. We've never opened it. We've never shown what's in it. Well, Kevin's going to share with you what's in that cabinet for the first. time. Oh, let's hear it. Another thing that I make for myself at the office is beer. The rules specifically say that you cannot bring beer into work, but it says nothing about making beer at work. Genius, huh? That's disgusting. Put that away. You're just jealous of my beer. Of your
所以如果你是凯文，坐在窗边的办公桌前，那里一直有一个大柜子。我们从来没打开过它。我们从来没展示过里面有什么。好吧，凯文要第一次和你分享那个柜子里有什么。哦，让我们听听。我在办公室里为自己做的另一件事是啤酒。规定明确说你不能带啤酒上班，但它没说不能在工作时酿啤酒。天才，对吧？真恶心。把它收起来。你只是嫉妒我的啤酒。你的
bacteria filled yeast water? I don't think so. Well, then Oscar, you may not have any. want any. Something burning. Oh, it's the creme brulee. Yes. So, yep, he has burned the creme brulee, but he says, you know what, it's okay. I can just make it again. And then he ends his cooking video with his sign-off message, and I think you should hear it. See you next time on Kevin Cook Stuff in the Office, where I will show you how to use
充满细菌的酵母水？我不这么认为。好吧，那奥斯卡，你不能喝。想要任何东西。有什么东西烧焦了。哦，是焦糖布丁。是的。所以，是的，他烧焦了焦糖布丁，但他说了，你知道吗，没关系。我可以再做一次。然后他用他的结束语结束了他的烹饪视频，我觉得你应该听听。下次在《办公室》里的《凯文做饭》再见，届时我将向你展示如何使用
ramen seasoning packets to make instant mashed potatoes. Even yum here. Huh. How about that? Ramen noodle seasoning and your mashed potatoes. I'm curious. I did not bring that in. Well, let's go eat some weird cassidia,
拉面调料包来制作速溶土豆泥。甚至更好吃。哈。怎么样？拉面调料和你的土豆泥。我很好奇。我没带那个。好吧，我们去吃点奇怪的墨西哥馅饼吧，
and then we'll be back in a moment. Well, we're back. Well, we're back, and we ate Kevin's cassidia. We did. We filmed it. We'll put it in stories. Cassie, smartly, opted not to try Kevin's cassidia, but Sam, me and Jenna did. Wow.
然后我们一会儿回来。好吧，我们回来了。好吧，我们回来了，我们吃了凯文的墨西哥馅饼。我们吃了。我们拍下来了。我们会把它放在故事里。凯西很聪明，选择不尝试凯文的墨西哥馅饼，但萨姆、我和珍娜吃了。哇。
Sam, you went first. What were your thoughts? It took a minute for that cheese taste to kick in, but once it did, it was there. It is strong. It was there. Yeah. Mine had cooled a little, and so I bit into what really felt like kind of a, it didn't not have the texture of food. It was very sort of like a plastic because I think the cheese
萨姆，你先吃的。你有什么想法？奶酪味过了一会儿才出来，但一旦出来，它就在那儿了。它很浓。它就在那儿。是的。我的冷却了一点，所以我咬下去的感觉真的有点像，它没有食物的质感。它非常像塑料，因为我觉得奶酪
had warmed and then congealed a little bit. Yeah. Mine was at first salty and I'm like, hey, I like a little salty snack. And then the cheese came at me hard and it kind of made my eyes water. I do not recommend. Not a fan. Not a snack. I would encourage others to eat. I'm not a fan, Kevin. I do want to tell you guys when I was at the grocery store looking for cheese was, I asked this young gal that worked there, and she had no idea what I was talking about. Oh. Had never heard of cheesewoods.
加热后又凝固了一点。是的。我的起初很咸，我想，嘿，我喜欢一点咸味零食。然后奶酪猛烈地冲击我，它让我的眼睛流泪了。我不推荐。不是粉丝。不是零食。我不会鼓励别人吃。我不是粉丝，凯文。我确实想告诉你们，当我在杂货店找奶酪酱时，我问了在那里工作的一个年轻女孩，她根本不知道我在说什么。哦。从来没听说过奶酪酱。
I think that's good. Well, I think that's good for our youth. I also want you to know the cheese was I bought was made. It said, with real cheese. Okay. So you're welcome. Thank you. All right.
我觉得那很好。好吧，我觉得这对我们的年轻人来说很好。我还想让你知道我买的奶酪酱是写着“用真正的奶酪制成”。好的。所以不客气。谢谢。好了。
Well, thank you, everyone, for participating in Ketka. Evan Cook Stuff, and today's recipe, casadias. I would like to request that we not ever try the crem brulee if that's okay with you. That's fine with me. Right. Well, are you ready now to hear the episode that was never produced, but that was titled Lunch slash the Nooner.
好吧，谢谢大家参与《凯文做饭》，今天的食谱是墨西哥馅饼。我想请求如果可以的话，我们永远不要尝试焦糖布丁。我没问题。好的。好吧，你现在准备好听那集从未制作过，但标题为《午餐/午间约会》的剧集了吗？
Do you know what a Nooner is? I do know what a Nooner is. Yes. Please tell me it's Bob and Phyllis. It is not good guess. This was a really fun pitch because it is Jan and Michael. Oh. Have a Nooner. But not at work. Not at work. Okay. So this is an episode that would have happened in season three. Okay. And it would have all started when Michael announces that he's leaving for an important lunch meeting with Jan. And he's says, he announces, so everyone's on their own for lunch. And then it said, someone remarks, we are always on our own for lunch. Right. What's the big announcement for? What are you up to? But nonetheless, people start making lunch plans. And it would have been a really cool episode because we would have seen little lunch routines and little stories coming up. So, for example, Pam, Karen, Phyllis, and Kelly, we're all going to sit around in the break room and have lunch.
你知道什么是“午间约会”吗？我知道什么是“午间约会”。是的。请告诉我那是鲍勃和菲利斯。不是，猜得好。这是一个非常有趣的构思，因为它是迈克尔和简。哦。有一个“午间约会”。但不是在工作时。不是在工作时。好的。所以这是一集本应发生在第三季的剧集。好的。一切都始于迈克尔宣布他要离开去和简开一个重要的午餐会议。他说，他宣布，所以每个人午餐都自便。然后有人评论说，我们午餐一直都是自便的。对。有什么大不了的宣布？你在搞什么鬼？但尽管如此，人们开始制定午餐计划。这将是一集非常酷的剧集，因为我们会看到小小的午餐惯例和即将出现的小故事。例如，帕姆、凯伦、菲利斯和凯利，她们都打算坐在休息室里吃午餐。
Kelly was going to be on a cleanse, and she won't stop talking about it. Okay. So then in our next lunch pairing, we find out that Oscar owes Kevin a lunch. Okay. And Kevin gets to decide where he wants to go. And he wants to go to this new place that he heard about that's supposed to have awesome pastrami sandwiches. So they head out together. And in their storyline, what would have happened was, when they get to this place, it's actually kind of like a romantic restaurant.
凯利本来要进行排毒，她会不停地谈论它。好的。然后在我们的下一个午餐配对中，我们发现奥斯卡欠凯文一顿午餐。好的。凯文可以决定他想去哪里。他想去一个他听说过的地方，据说那里有很棒的熏牛肉三明治。所以他们一起出发了。在他们的故事线中，会发生的是，当他们到达这个地方时，它实际上有点像一家浪漫的餐厅。
So it's not just like ye oldie sand. sandwich shop. No. No. And it's like cloth table cloths and cloth napkins, a very formal lunch. And they're a little uncomfortable, but they end up bonding. So it's like a happy story. Guess what Stanley does for lunch. Stanley? Takes a nap. Yes, lady. He drives around the corner, parks his car, eats a sandwich, and then falls asleep. You're so right. Dwight and Angela. have a lunch date. Aw. But then, Dwight's friends were going to come to work and surprise him and take him to lunch.
所以它不仅仅是那种老式三明治店。不。不。它有布桌布和布餐巾，非常正式的午餐。他们有点不舒服，但最终建立了联系。所以这是一个快乐的故事。猜猜斯坦利午餐做什么。斯坦利？打个盹。是的，莱迪。他开车绕过拐角，停好车，吃个三明治，然后睡着了。你说得太对了。德怀特和安吉拉有一个午餐约会。噢。但后来，德怀特的朋友们要来公司给他惊喜，带他去吃午餐。
But the real surprise is that they have brought along his girlfriend, who is back from her 18-month tour of Kuwait. Do you remember? This was like very early season storyline that Dwight had this girlfriend who was active duty military in Kuwait. Well, she's back. Whoa. I know. And apparently Dwight has not spoken to her since she left. And hasn't told Angela that they're still dating.
但真正的惊喜是他们带来了他的女朋友，她刚从科威特18个月的巡回演出回来。你还记得吗？这是第三季非常早期的故事线，德怀特有一个在科威特服现役的女朋友。好吧，她回来了。哇。我知道。而且显然德怀特自从她离开后就没和她说过话。也没告诉安吉拉他们还在约会。
I mean, that's the thing. Are they still dating? We don't know. So Dwight goes off to lunch at Coopers. And Angela has to stay behind. So now Angela folds into the group of women in the break room. I see. In the break room.
我的意思是，这就是问题所在。他们还在约会吗？我们不知道。所以德怀特去库珀餐厅吃午餐了。而安吉拉不得不留下来。所以现在安吉拉融入了休息室里的女性群体。我明白了。在休息室里。
Probably not in a great mood. Mm-hmm. So next up, we have Karen, who the pitch says is trying to be more like Pam and be more fun with Jim. So she's going to suggest that she and Jim go out to the same restaurant and spy on Dwight and his date. So they do. They go to the restaurant and they try to very discreetly sit at a different table and eavesdrop. But this gal sees them and is like, oh, my gosh, why don't you come join us? So now Karen and Jim are having a double date with Dwight and his military girlfriend.
可能心情不太好。嗯哼。接下来是凯伦，构思说她正试图变得更像帕姆，和吉姆一起更有趣。所以她建议她和吉姆去同一家餐厅，监视德怀特和他的约会对象。他们确实去了。他们去了餐厅，试图非常谨慎地坐在另一张桌子旁偷听。但这个女孩看到了他们，说，哦，天哪，你们为什么不加入我们？所以现在凯伦和吉姆正在和德怀特以及他的军人女友进行双重约会。
Yes, exactly. And listen to how she was described, Angela. This was going to be a lot of drama for Dwight and Angela. She's described as being outgoing, athletic, outdoorsy, a little offbeat, but still normal, tough, but still feminine. She's telling Dwight war stories, and he is in awe of her. Jim and Karen can't believe what a great match it is. I mean, it sounds perfect. Well, the ladies are going to go to the bathroom, and Dwight is going to turn to Jim and ask for relationship advice.
是的，完全正确。听听她是怎么被描述的，安吉拉。这对德怀特和安吉拉来说将会有很多戏剧性。她被描述为外向、运动型、喜欢户外活动、有点另类，但仍然正常、坚强，但仍然女性化。她正在给德怀特讲战争故事，而他被她迷住了。吉姆和凯伦不敢相信他们是多么般配。我的意思是，听起来很完美。好吧，女士们要去洗手间，德怀特要转向吉姆寻求恋爱建议。
Because you know who Dwight really wants to be with is Angela. So this was going to kind of start a runner where Jim was going to be like counseling Dwight on relationships. Meanwhile, back at the office, the rest of the women continue to have lunch. But they have not included Meredith. Why not? She's not invited to eat with them. Oh. Yes.
因为你知道德怀特真正想在一起的人是安吉拉。所以这会开启一个连载，吉姆会像是在给德怀特提供恋爱咨询。与此同时，回到办公室，剩下的女性继续吃午餐。但她们没有包括梅雷迪思。为什么不？她没被邀请和她们一起吃。哦。是的。
She is forced to eat alone with Andy. I will say it doesn't sound like Angela was invited either. She just showed up. Yeah, she shows up the table and it says she's distracted and grouchy. But guess what? Andy and Meredith start to bond. They realize they both have problems that they're trying to get. get over. They both feel like outcasts. And they start giving each other life advice. That I would have
她被迫和安迪单独吃饭。我会说听起来安吉拉也没被邀请。她只是出现了。是的，她出现在桌子旁，说她心不在焉且脾气暴躁。但你猜怎么着？安迪和梅雷迪思开始建立联系。他们意识到他们都有试图克服的问题。他们都觉得自己是局外人。他们开始给对方生活建议。那是我
wanted to see. I love this pairing of Andy and Meredith. Yes. Well, during all of this, remember, this all started because Michael was going to go have lunch with Jan. There were going to be spy shots where we see that Michael actually drives to meet Jan at a Howard Johnson's. A motel in the afternoon. That's the nooner. And they are going to come down from the hotel room. They're in a great mood. They actually do have lunch at the little attached diner. And through a series of spy shots, we were going to see their conversation. And it's not great. It said there's a sampling of Jan's quote, increasing craziness. And for a long, long beat, there's no conversation at all. And they just eat in silence. Michael was going to float the idea.
想看到的。我喜欢安迪和梅雷迪思这对组合。是的。好吧，在这一切过程中，记住，这一切始于迈克尔要和简去吃午餐。会有间谍镜头，我们看到迈克尔实际上开车去霍华德约翰逊酒店见简。下午的一家汽车旅馆。那就是“午间约会”。他们会从酒店房间下来。他们心情很好。他们确实在旁边的小餐馆吃了午餐。通过一系列间谍镜头，我们将看到他们的谈话。情况不太好。据说有简的“日益疯狂”的语录样本。而且有很长很长一段时间，根本没有谈话。他们只是沉默地吃饭。迈克尔本来要提出
of breaking up, but Jan distracts him by suggesting they go back up to the hotel room for another quickie. And ultimately, Michael's going to come back to the office and say he and Jan are doing great. It was a great meeting. This makes me sad. I know. This is sort of like foreshadowing for dinner party. So much foreshadowing. Well, that was the pitch for lunch slash the nooner. Can you guess what the tag was going to be for this episode. You guessed Stanley sleeping in his car. There's going to be another moment in a car. Oh, Lord. Is it like Andy getting a hand job from Meredith? Yes. What? It was that Andy and Meredith have sex in her car. That was the tag. I had no idea. I just completely threw that out there. Wow. Well, a lunch episode would have packed some surprises. Yes, pretty fun.
分手的想法，但简通过建议他们回到酒店房间再来一次快餐来分散他的注意力。最终，迈克尔会回到办公室说他和简相处得很好。那是一次很棒的会议。这让我很难过。我知道。这有点像《晚宴》的伏笔。太多的伏笔了。好吧，这就是《午餐/午间约会》的构思。你能猜出这一集的标签会是什么吗？你猜对了斯坦利在车里睡觉。车里会有另一个时刻。哦，天哪。是安迪从梅雷迪思那里得到手淫吗？是的。什么？是安迪和梅雷迪思在她的车里做爱。那就是标签。我完全不知道。我只是随口一说。哇。好吧，午餐剧集会带来一些惊喜。是的，很有趣。
Well, speaking of lunch, I want to hear this segue way. You know, before the break, we talked a lot about the food in the world of the office, the stuff we had to eat in scenes, but there was a whole other world behind the scenes, our amazing catering and craft service. Yes, they were wonderful. There's part of our book, The Office BFFs, where we share about. craft service and catering and like what meals look like on the set. And I'm so glad it's there. Craft services and Peter and Vartan and Sergio and catering and his team were such a big part of our community on the office. We wrote about it in our book, The Office BFFs. And we both have really special memories, as does the whole cast and crew of meal time on the office.
好吧，说到午餐，我想听听这个过渡。你知道，在休息之前，我们谈了很多关于《办公室》世界里的食物，我们在场景中必须吃的那些东西，但幕后还有一个完全不同的世界，我们出色的餐饮和工艺服务。是的，他们太棒了。我们书《办公室最好的朋友》的一部分，我们分享了关于工艺服务和餐饮，以及片场的餐食是什么样的。我很高兴它在那里。工艺服务和彼得、瓦尔坦以及塞尔吉奥和餐饮团队是我们《办公室》社区的重要组成部分。我们在书《办公室最好的朋友》中写到了它。我们俩都有非常特别的记忆，整个演员和工作人员对《办公室》的用餐时间也是如此。
Well, I just can't say enough about how these two teams kept our set going. You know, we were stuck. We can't go out for food or snacks. We're totally dependent on these teams. And I just, I was thinking back on all the ways that they would take care of us, like the little things like if we were shooting someplace outside and we were cold, you know, Peter and Vartan would put out hot soup to warm us up, you know? And all the care that Sergio took in our meals, even making special meals when our kids came to set. And I mean, Jenna, I don't know how we would have gotten through our pregnancies without Peter and Vartan. I know.
好吧，我怎么夸这两个团队如何维持我们的片场都不为过。你知道，我们被困住了。我们不能出去吃东西或零食。我们完全依赖这些团队。我只是，我在回想他们照顾我们的所有方式，比如如果我们去外面拍摄，我们很冷，你知道，彼得和瓦尔坦会端出热汤来温暖我们，你知道吗？还有塞尔吉奥在我们的餐食中投入的所有关怀，甚至在我们的孩子来到片场时制作特别餐食。我的意思是，珍娜，我不知道如果没有彼得和瓦尔坦，我们怎么度过怀孕期。我知道。
They really fed us and nurtured us. And, you know, I found a journal entry where I wrote about Peter and Vartan. Oh, are you going to read it? Yeah, I'm going to read it. Okay, great. It's a real short little entry, but it just speaks to how they took care of us. So at the top, it says July 21st, 2011, 4.02 p.m. You know, I always say what type it is. And I wrote, I had the day off from work today, but I had to go in for a wardrobe fitting. I brought
他们真的喂养了我们，滋养了我们。而且，你知道，我发现了一篇日记，我写到了彼得和瓦尔坦。哦，你要读它吗？是的，我要读它。好的，太棒了。这是一篇很短的小条目，但它只是说明了他们是如何照顾我们的。所以在顶部，它写着2011年7月21日，下午4点02分。你知道，我总是说是什么类型。我写道，我今天休息，但我必须去进行服装试穿。我带了
Isabel with me. After my fitting, we had lunch on set, and Peter and Vartan were so sweet. They brought Isabel a special snack, cupcakes and a smoothie. We had such a fun day. I love that lady. Isn't that so cute? Well, lady, I don't think there is anyone on our set who loved our food more than BJ Novak. BJ is like a foodie. Like, for real, he's a foodie. He has a whole business now called Eat a Chain. I know, right? And it's like Michelin Star chefs. Yes. Turn your fast food favorites into like these elevated meals. Right. And they're delicious. I went to the Chili's one. I've been to two now. One, I took the kids with. They had a pop-up of all these different types of food chains.
伊莎贝尔和我一起。试穿后，我们在片场吃了午餐，彼得和瓦尔坦太贴心了。他们给伊莎贝尔带了一个特别的零食，纸杯蛋糕和冰沙。我们度过了如此有趣的一天。我喜欢那个，莱迪。那不是太可爱了吗？好吧，莱迪，我不认为我们的片场有任何人比BJ·诺瓦克更爱我们的食物。BJ就像一个美食家。真的，他是一个美食家。他现在有一个完整的生意叫“Eat a Chain”。我知道，对吧？而且是米其林星级厨师。是的。把你的快餐最爱变成这些高级餐点。对。而且它们很美味。我去了Chili's那家。我现在去过两家了。一家，我带了孩子们去。他们有一个所有这些不同类型食品连锁店的快闪店。
Delicious. So good. So good. Well, he invited our catering craft service teams to be on the DVD commentary track for season five business ethics. I remember. So I reached out to him. And lady, I don't know if he's ever responded to me faster. He is so excited about food. I remember when I came across that commentary years ago and I texted him, he was like, no way. Where can I find it? he was so excited that it still lived somewhere. Yeah. Well, he sent in an audio clip. He has some advice for people who might be new to a set. Oh, I can't wait to hear this. On how to get the best stuff. If I have any advice in show business, I have one piece of advice that I'm 100% sure of that I tell everyone, which is that if you want coffee on a set, get it from craft services, not catering. When you arrive in the morning, there's going to be a truck that has all types of
美味。太好了。太好了。好吧，他邀请了我们的餐饮工艺服务团队参加第五季《商业道德》的DVD评论音轨。我记得。所以我联系了他。莱迪，我不知道他是否曾经更快地回复过我。他对食物太兴奋了。我记得几年前我偶然发现那个评论时，我给他发了短信，他说，不会吧。我在哪里可以找到它？他太兴奋了，它还存在于某个地方。是的。好吧，他发来了一个音频片段。他给那些可能刚到片场的人一些建议。哦，我迫不及待想听这个。关于如何获得最好的东西。如果我在演艺界有什么建议，我有一个我100%确定的建议，我告诉每个人，那就是如果你想在片场喝咖啡，从工艺服务那里拿，而不是餐饮。当你早上到达时，会有一辆卡车，上面有各种各样的
great food and they're going to have coffee on that truck. Do not get the coffee from the truck because they make coffee as an afterthought. Then there's craft services which make snacks and all that stuff, but coffee is what they do. That's what they're judged on. Go the extra 20 feet. Get your coffee from craft services, not catering. Catering is great, but coffee is not their thing. It's not their focus, nor should it be. Lady, do you hear the passion in his voice? Like, he is literally telling people where to get coffee on a set the way I beg people to go get their cancer screenings.
很棒的食物，他们会在那辆卡车上有咖啡。不要从卡车上拿咖啡，因为他们把咖啡当作事后想到的东西。然后有工艺服务，他们制作零食和所有那些东西，但咖啡是他们的专长。那是他们被评判的标准。多走20英尺。从工艺服务那里拿你的咖啡，而不是餐饮。餐饮很棒，但咖啡不是他们的强项。这不是他们的重点，也不应该是。莱迪，你听到他声音里的激情了吗？就像，他真的在告诉人们在片场哪里可以买到咖啡，就像我乞求人们去进行癌症筛查一样。
That cracked me up. The absolute, like, seriousness. Yes. And he's right. He is right. I don't drink coffee, as you know, but I know craft services, they are sort of connoisseurs. stores of like beverages and they do smoothies. They do coffee. They do hot cocoa. I mean, they have a gazillion types of teas. They are where you go for beverage. Correct. He also talked
那让我笑死了。绝对的，就像，严肃性。是的。他是对的。他是对的。我不喝咖啡，如你所知，但我知道工艺服务，他们有点像饮料鉴赏家，他们做冰沙。他们做咖啡。他们做热可可。我的意思是，他们有无数种茶。他们是你去买饮料的地方。正确。他还谈到了
a little bit about the food in the writer's room, which is not provided by craft services or catering. That's right. They have their own writer's assistant who has to manage food for the writers. And, you know, this is because their hours would sometimes, they didn't coordinate with our hours. Like, they would be their writing until like 10 p.m. or midnight. And then they also don't come in till 10 a.m. sometimes. Yes. So they kind of had their whole own food situation. And here's what he had to say about that. Snacks are, it's like when you're a babysitter, it's all about what the people's cabinets have, what snacks they have. And same for a writer's room. and to what snacks are there, and we went through periods where we had every snack in the world.
一点关于编剧室里的食物，那不是由工艺服务或餐饮提供的。没错。他们有自己的编剧助理，必须为编剧管理食物。而且，你知道，这是因为他们的工作时间有时，他们不与我们的时间协调。比如，他们会写到晚上10点或午夜。然后他们有时也不到上午10点才来。是的。所以他们有自己的一套食物情况。这是他对此的看法。零食是，就像当你是一个保姆时，一切都取决于人们的橱柜里有什么，他们有什么零食。编剧室也是如此。关于有什么零食，我们经历过我们拥有世界上每一种零食的时期。
It was turkey jerky from Trader Joe's was the favorite snack, but it was all of these terribly salty Trader Joe's snacks. And then every now and then we get disgusted with ourselves. We'd gain a lot of weight, and we would ban all unhealthy foods from the writer's room and put them in the fridge and freezer by set. So you could get an ice cream cone, but you had to walk to the freezer in the other trailer. and then we would slip, it would just be a cycle. So this is exactly how I remember the writer's room snacks, too,
那是Trader Joe's的火鸡肉干是最受欢迎的零食，但那全是这些非常咸的Trader Joe's零食。然后每隔一段时间我们就会对自己感到厌恶。我们会增加很多体重，我们会禁止编剧室里所有的不健康食品，把它们放在片场旁边的冰箱和冰柜里。所以你可以得到一个冰淇淋蛋筒，但你必须走到另一辆拖车里的冰柜。然后我们会滑倒，这只是一个循环。所以这正是我也记得编剧室零食的方式，
because I remember they had this back stairwell that went up to their kitchen, and sometimes we went up that way, and it would be either feast or famine in there. It would either be, like, seriously, every type of, like, Little Debbie Cupcake or whatever, to then just like, nothing. Nothing are just like a rice cake. Yes. They did go through a whole like rice cake phase. Yeah. And then when they were going through that phase, that's when they got like a treadmill, remember? But yeah, there was a real yo-yo effect with their snacks. Well, you know, our first AD, Kelly Cantley, I was texting with her and I said, hey, we're going to talk to Sergio for this food episode. I'm curious, like, what's your breakfast order? Well, lady, she gave me the scoop on her breakfast. order and also Sergio's doing something new. She said that on the office, her breakfast order was either
因为我记得他们有那个通往他们厨房的后楼梯，有时我们走那条路，那里要么是盛宴，要么是饥荒。要么是，真的，每一种Little Debbie纸杯蛋糕之类的，然后就什么都没有。什么都没有，或者只是像米饼。是的。他们确实经历过整个米饼阶段。是的。然后当他们经历那个阶段时，那就是他们得到跑步机的时候，记得吗？但是的，他们的零食确实有一种真正的溜溜球效应。好吧，你知道，我们的第一助理导演，凯利·坎特利，我正在和她发短信，我说，嘿，我们要为这集美食节目和塞尔吉奥谈谈。我很好奇，你的早餐订单是什么？好吧，莱迪，她给了我关于她早餐订单的内幕，而且塞尔吉奥正在做一些新的事情。她说在《办公室》里，她的早餐订单要么是
a baby burrito with bacon and no salsa or one scrambled egg with a side of black beans and avocado. Black beans and avocado is big on our set. But she said on the paper, Sergio has updated all the things that she likes and now serves breakfast as a mini taco. I mean, yeah, he takes one tater tot and he smashes it in the bottom of each mini taco and then he'll put whatever your breakfast order is inside. She said it's genius. Sign me up. You had me at smashed tater tot. She said if he had a taco stand or a restaurant, I would go every day. Oh my gosh. That's a, sounds so good. Well, you know, I was trading text with Sergio about being on the podcast. Talk about
一个带培根且没有莎莎酱的婴儿墨西哥卷饼，或者一个炒蛋配黑豆和牛油果。黑豆和牛油果在我们的片场很受欢迎。但她说在《纸》上，塞尔吉奥更新了她喜欢的所有东西，现在把早餐作为迷你塔可饼供应。我的意思是，是的，他拿一个炸薯球，把它压在每个迷你塔可饼的底部，然后他会把你点的任何早餐放进去。她说这是天才。算我一个。你用压碎的炸薯球吸引了我。她说如果他有一个塔可饼摊或餐厅，我会每天都去。哦，天哪。那听起来太棒了。好吧，你知道，我正在和塞尔吉奥交换关于参加播客的短信。谈谈
someone who responded right away with such enthusiasm, much like BJ. He could not wait to talk to us. He's such a lovely person, and we had so much fun going down memory lane with him. We did. We zoomed with him the other day, and we can't wait for you to hear our chat with him. So here is our chat with Sergio. Hello, Sergio. Hi there. Thank you for coming on the podcast. I love the podcast, by the way. You all have nice voices, so it's suiting to the ear.
一个立刻以如此热情回应的人，就像BJ一样。他迫不及待地想和我们谈谈。他是一个如此可爱的人，我们和他一起回忆过去玩得很开心。我们确实。我们前几天和他进行了视频通话，我们迫不及待地想让你听到我们和他聊天。所以这是我们和塞尔吉奥的聊天。你好，塞尔吉奥。你好。谢谢你来参加播客。顺便说一句，我喜欢这个播客。你们都有好听的声音，所以很悦耳。
It's funny and it's a lot of fun. Oh, thanks, Sergio. It was so nice seeing you when we visited the paper. I know. I like that. That was such a surprise. We were slammed for breakfast, but it was nice seeing you guys.
它很有趣，而且很有意思。哦，谢谢，塞尔吉奥。当我们参观《纸》时见到你真是太好了。我知道。我喜欢那个。那真是一个惊喜。我们早餐忙得不可开交，但见到你们真是太好了。
And then also being on that show, you know, kind of like, you know, having some of the crew members from the office and, you know, Oscar. It was awesome doing that show too. It just brings a lot of memories of what we had in the office, you know? Well, Sergio, you are so loved. I have noticed pretty much every time I'm on a set where Mindy's running the show, you're there. Like the office family loves you and they always want to. work with you. Yeah, no, I appreciate that. It's been amazing being part of the office, you know,
然后也参加那个节目，你知道，有点像，你知道，有《办公室》的一些工作人员，还有，你知道，奥斯卡。做那个节目也很棒。它只是带回了很多我们在《办公室》里的记忆，你知道吗？好吧，塞尔吉奥，你太受爱戴了。我注意到几乎每次我在明迪主持节目的片场，你都在那里。《办公室》的家人爱你，他们总是想和你一起工作。是的，不，我很感激。成为《办公室》的一部分真是太棒了，你知道，
because we had a lot of great times, right? It was such an amazing time. And for me, as a cook, and cooking for y'all, it was special. You know, you mentioned breakfast and Kelly shared with us that you have started doing mini tacos for breakfast. She said you took her breakfast order and put it in a tiny taco, and she said she can't get enough of it. Yeah, Kelly, it was awesome working with Kelly. And yeah, she has like little orders, small orders, kind of like Angela. When Angela, you order her little Angela size. Yeah, Angie's size.
因为我们有很多美好的时光，对吧？那是一段如此美好的时光。对我来说，作为一个厨师，为你们所有人做饭，这很特别。你知道，你提到了早餐，凯利和我们分享说你已经开始做迷你塔可饼作为早餐了。她说你拿了她的早餐订单，把它放进了一个小塔可饼里，她说她怎么吃都不够。是的，凯利，和凯利一起工作太棒了。而且是的，她有像小订单，小订单，有点像安吉拉。当安吉拉，你点她的小安吉拉尺寸。是的，安吉尺寸。
Yeah, that was fun. So, Sergio, you have been in this food business for so long. How do you keep coming up with new ideas and new recipes? We're so curious how you put a menu together for the week. Well, when I started the office, it was hard because there was no iPhone, right? And I had to go through the cookbooks, you know, and just get the ideas from there. And the feedback from the crew, that's kind of like what you work with. Like, oh, they like this or, you know, we're going that direction.
是的，那很有趣。所以，塞尔吉奥，你在这个食品行业已经这么久了。你是如何不断想出新点子和新食谱的？我们很好奇你是如何为这一周制定菜单的。好吧，当我开始《办公室》时，这很难，因为没有iPhone，对吧？我不得不翻阅食谱，你知道，从那里得到点子。还有来自工作人员的反馈，这有点像你工作的方式。比如，哦，他们喜欢这个，或者，你知道，我们正朝着那个方向发展。
But, yeah, it got easier when the iPhone came around, you know. So it was just a lot easier. But, yeah, it was through crew members, what they like and all that. So I have to ask. you know, you're using word of mouth about what's a hit, what's not. Was there a recipe you ever did that people were like, don't do that one again? Or was there one where everyone was like, you have to do that one again? Like, what are your hits and your, your, your misses? They never really tell you like, oh, that wasn't good, you know? I never, I only got that once. And that was the
但是，是的，当iPhone出现时，它变得更容易了，你知道。所以这容易多了。但是，是的，这是通过工作人员，他们喜欢什么以及所有这些。所以我必须问。你知道，你正在使用口碑关于什么是热门，什么是失败。有没有你做过的食谱，人们说“别再做那个了”？或者有没有一个每个人都说“你必须再做一次”？比如，什么是你的热门和你的失败？他们从来没有真正告诉你，比如，哦，那不好吃，你知道？我只得到过一次。那是
teamsters in New York, you know, one time. But only like as a family, like, that really liked me a lot. They told me, hey, we love you, but that last meal, you know, that's the only time. They told me, but it was the Teamsters in New York, you know. But other than that with the office and all that, everybody was so nice. It was beautiful. Well, your food is amazing. That's why I couldn't believe anyone would ever tell you this was a miss. But, you know, Jen and I both had so many meals that we loved.
纽约的卡车司机，你知道，有一次。但只是像一个家庭，你知道，真的很喜欢我。他们告诉我，嘿，我们爱你，但上一顿饭，你知道，那是唯一一次。他们告诉我，但那是纽约的卡车司机，你知道。但除此之外，在《办公室》和所有这些，每个人都太好了。这很美。好吧，你的食物太棒了。这就是为什么我不敢相信有人会告诉你这是一个失败。但是，你知道，珍和我都吃过很多我们喜欢的饭菜。
What was your most requested meal? The most requested meal. it's the action stations, you know, like the pasta bars, the taco bars, the crew always love that, the action station. So every time we had like a fun station and, you know, especially the pasta bar and the taco bar, those are always a hit. Well, I remember your pasta bar. I was a fan and you would have like all the different pastas and all the different ingredients and then different sauces and it was kind of like an omelette bar. You just walk up and point to all the things you wanted
你最常被点的餐是什么？最常被点的餐。是行动站，你知道，比如意大利面吧，塔可饼吧，工作人员总是喜欢那个，行动站。所以每次我们有像一个有趣的站，你知道，特别是意大利面吧和塔可饼吧，那些总是很受欢迎。好吧，我记得你的意大利面吧。我是粉丝，你会像有所有不同的意大利面和所有不同的配料，然后不同的酱汁，它有点像煎蛋卷吧。你只是走过去，指向你想要的所有东西
and you guys would make it right there on the spot. Yeah. It was so great. It was fun. I tried and have it. So when like also when I went Isabella, when she was young, she used to just eat plain pasta, right? Yeah.
你们就会当场做出来。是的。太棒了。很有趣。我试过，也有。所以当像我也去伊莎贝尔，当她年轻时，她过去只是吃纯意大利面，对吧？是的。
That was her go-to. So, you know, it reminds me of that too when Isabella was young coming to set. You were so sweet with her. You would always set aside. a little buttered noodles dish for her. You took such good care of all of us in that way. Yeah, you know, we grew into a family there. And there's nothing like that, you know, ever going to happen again.
那是她的首选。所以，你知道，这也让我想起了伊莎贝尔年轻时来到片场。你对她太贴心了。你总是会为她留出一份黄油面条。你以那种方式照顾了我们所有人。是的，你知道，我们在那里成长为一个家庭。而且没有什么像那样，你知道，会再次发生。
I don't think once in a lifetime. Another thing, Sergio, is that you were able to like make a meal that was good for the people who were dairy-free and gluten-free and vegetarian. And you would have a meat option, but then you would have also a fish option. How do you do it? also at breakfast, I never heard anybody order breakfast and you didn't have whatever the thing was. Like, this is a silly question, but where do you keep all this food? And who does the grocery shopping? How do you do this? Yeah. So, so when it started, you know, season one, um, the
我不认为一生一次。另一件事，塞尔吉奥，是你能够为那些不吃乳制品、不含麸质和素食的人做出一顿好饭。你会有一个肉类选择，但你也会有一个鱼类选择。你是怎么做到的？早餐时也是，我从来没听说过有人点早餐而你没有那个东西。比如，这是一个愚蠢的问题，但你把所有这些食物放在哪里？谁负责买菜？你是怎么做到的？是的。所以，所以当它开始时，你知道，第一季，嗯，
meas and place for breakfast was a little bit small, but as the show grew in the, into the years, you know, like by the third season, you know, same crew members, the cast and, and, and, and, And so everybody had their little, you know, little specialty. So I had to make sure I had this, had to make sure I had goat cheese because a couple orders, you know, and it grew the meas and plus for breakfast. It grew like more and more as the years went on. By the ninth season, I had a lot of stuff in the fridge. I bet.
早餐的准备工作有点小，但随着节目的成长，进入这些年，你知道，到第三季，你知道，同样的船员，演员和，和，和，每个人都有他们的小，你知道，小特色。所以我必须确保我有这个，必须确保我有山羊奶酪，因为几个订单，你知道，早餐的准备工作增长了。它随着岁月的流逝增长得越来越多。到第九季，我在冰箱里有很多东西。我敢打赌。
I bet you did. I mean, I feel like there were people who were like, I want my breakfast order, but will you throw some like hot peppers on it today. And you'd say, sure. Yeah. Oh, yeah. Especially I had had the Rashida special. That one was a hit, right? Remember the Rashida special? That one was such a hit. So I had to have black beans. I had to have, you know, turkey bacon. Every day, every day and all that because corn tortillas, the green salsa, you know. Yeah, that one really took off. Yeah, I took off. That's got that for a while, too. You know, Sergio, I was so curious.
我敢打赌你有。我的意思是，我觉得有些人就像，我想要我的早餐订单，但你今天能往上面撒点热辣椒吗。你会说，当然。是的。哦，是的。特别是我有拉什达特餐。那个很受欢迎，对吧？记得拉什达特餐吗？那个太受欢迎了。所以我必须有黑豆。我必须有，你知道，火鸡培根。每天，每天，所有这些，因为玉米饼，绿色莎莎酱，你知道。是的，那个真的很火。是的，我火了一段时间。你知道，塞尔吉奥，我很好奇。
I've always wanted to ask you this. How did you start as a chef? What was your journey to doing this? So I started, you know, this catering company as a dishwasher at 18. And then I moved up, moved up the ranks. And then they gave me a shot, the catering company I was at. They gave me a shot as a chef, kind of young, like at 24. and I was like chef in commercials.
我一直想问你这个。你是怎么开始当厨师的？你做这个的旅程是什么？所以我开始，你知道，这个餐饮公司是在18岁时当洗碗工。然后我晋升，晋升。然后他们给了我一个机会，我在的那家餐饮公司。他们给了我一个机会当厨师，有点年轻，像24岁。我当时就像商业广告里的厨师。
That's all I were doing. So I had like five-day recipes. That's all I needed for commercials. And so then I got the call to do the office. So the office was my first show and like full on five days a week, months, you know. So I was real nervous. Like I was nervous on the first day. And then the second day, the craft service then, it was another craft.
我做的就是这些。所以我像有五天的食谱。这就是我做商业广告所需要的全部。然后我接到了做《办公室》的电话。所以《办公室》是我的第一个节目，就像全职每周五天，几个月，你知道。所以我真的很紧张。比如我在第一天很紧张。然后第二天，工艺服务，那是另一个工艺。
It wasn't Peter and Rotten. But that crap service told me on the second day, they said they were talking about you. And I was like real horrified that they were like something bad. Yeah. And it was good news, right? He says, they were talking good about your food. And that gave me the confidence to try hard and all that.
那不是彼得和罗滕。但那个糟糕的服务部门在第二天告诉我，他们说他们在谈论你。我当时真的很害怕，以为他们说了什么坏话。是的。结果是好消息，对吧？他说，他们都在夸你的食物做得好。这给了我努力工作的信心，诸如此类。
And it was such a nice crew that it was easy to do. But I learned a lot through the office, you know, through the casting crew. I learned a lot like, you know, like through the cooking and took it, took it with me to the other show. shows. But yeah, office was my school. How much did you coordinate with Michael and Vartan? Because they would bring out like a certain hot snack every day at 10 o'clock.
那是一个非常棒的团队，所以工作起来很容易。但我通过办公室，你知道，通过选角团队学到了很多。我学到了很多，比如，通过烹饪，并把它带到了其他节目中。是的，办公室就是我的学校。你和迈克尔以及瓦尔坦协调了多少？因为他们每天10点都会拿出某种热乎乎的零食。
And did you guys talk? Like, were you sure to be like, okay, if they're doing a hot dog bar, I'm not going to do hot dogs at lunch? We did. We tried. But for some reason, we still always ended up doing the same thing. You know, kind of, you know, like, oh, you're doing that. Oh, that's so funny.
你们交流过吗？比如，你会确认一下，好吧，如果他们要做热狗吧，我就不在午餐时做热狗了？我们做过。我们尝试过。但出于某种原因，我们最终还是做了同样的事情。你知道，那种，你知道，比如，哦，你在做那个。哦，那太有趣了。
I don't have that memory at all. Yeah, I don't either. I was like somehow you guys never managed to double up in my mind. Okay, that's good because, yeah, Peter and my friend is to, you know, like we come up with something. I'm doing that today. But, yeah, there were so much fun with those two guys, man. I love them. And I miss them.
我完全没有那个记忆。是的，我也没有。我当时想，不知何故，你们在我的印象中从来没有重复过。好吧，那很好，因为，是的，彼得和我的朋友，你知道，我们想出了一些东西。我今天要做那个。但是，是的，和那两个人在一起太有趣了，伙计。我爱他们。我很想念他们。
Yeah, same. You know, Sergio, I'm so curious, too. because you are planning meals all the time and huge meals too. Do you plan any meals at home? Are you just like once you're home, you are done meal planning? No, I do. I actually cook for my boys on the weekend.
是的，我也是。你知道，塞尔吉奥，我也很好奇。因为你一直在计划餐食，而且是大量的餐食。你在家里也计划餐食吗？还是说一旦你回到家，你就完成了餐食计划？不，我会的。我实际上在周末为我的孩子们做饭。
I see them on the weekend. So we do every weekend, I do a dinner and we watch movies. And at home, I like to cook here too. It's a lot funner. and, you know, get to experience new stuff. I like cooking at home. Except when I'm working, if I'm working, then, you know, only that Saturday is the only day I'll cook.
我周末会见到他们。所以我们每个周末都做，我做晚餐，我们看电影。在家里，我也喜欢在这里做饭。这更有趣，而且，你知道，可以体验新事物。我喜欢在家里做饭。除了我工作的时候，如果我在工作，那么，你知道，只有周六是我会做饭的一天。
Oh, that's fair, I think. Yeah, yeah. Well, you know, I love your food so much that when I worked on the office, I would go through the lunch line and I would pick something for lunch. And then I would wait for everybody to eat. And then as you all would start to kind of pack up stuff, like lunch was over, I would go through and I would get one of your to-go containers and I would pick something and that's what I would eat for dinner. Yeah. Oh, that's nice. So I would eat your food twice a day for all
哦，我觉得这很公平。是的，是的。嗯，你知道，我非常喜欢你的食物，以至于我在办公室工作时，我会走过午餐线，挑选一些午餐。然后我会等大家吃完。然后当你们开始收拾东西，比如午餐结束时，我会走过去，拿一个你的外带容器，挑选一些东西，那就是我晚餐要吃的东西。是的。哦，那太好了。所以我每天吃两次你的食物，在那
those years on the office. Thank you so much. I appreciate that, Jenna. Thank you. Yeah. Yeah, there was many times we were taking food home. Oh, yeah. Sergio, do you have a favorite food memory from the office or a behind the scenes memory? It doesn't have to be food related. just from your time on the show? Yeah, it's my most memorable one. It was kind of a sad one, but it was Steve Carell's last day, and we went to the warehouse, and he did that beautiful speech. And then we took the time to talk to every department, you know.
在办公室工作的那些年里。非常感谢。我很感激，珍娜。谢谢。是的。是的，有很多次我们把食物带回家。哦，是的。塞尔吉奥，你对办公室有什么最喜欢的食物记忆或幕后记忆吗？不一定非要与食物有关。只是你在节目中的那段时间？是的，这是我最难忘的一次。那有点悲伤，那是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔的最后一天，我们去了仓库，他发表了那段美丽的演讲。然后我们花时间与每个部门交谈，你知道。
And I'll never forget it. It's like, you know, there wasn't a dry eye, the room where everybody was. It was the most memorable one that I'll never forget. Yeah. Have you run into Steve since the office wrapped? Yes. Yes. So when Vartan passed away, I found out, you know, about it through Debbie.
我永远不会忘记它。就像，你知道，每个人都热泪盈眶，那个房间里每个人都在。这是我永远不会忘记的最难忘的一次。是的。办公室结束后你见过史蒂夫吗？是的。是的。所以当瓦尔坦去世时，我通过黛比知道了这件事。
And me, Alan, and Debbie went. And we were right there at the funeral. And then it was, you know, us three and in-walk, Steve Carell. And it was like, it was us four right there. And that's, you know, that's a beautiful moment. And we got to talk with Steve Correel about the office. And that was the last time I saw him. I also saw him on Space Force.
我和艾伦还有黛比去了。我们就在葬礼现场。然后，你知道，我们三个人，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔走了进来。就像，我们四个人就在那里。而且，你知道，那是一个美丽的时刻。我们和史蒂夫·卡瑞尔谈论了办公室。那是我最后一次见到他。我也在《太空部队》里见过他。
But the last time was Vartan, I believe. Yeah. I know several people have always asked us about the different menus on the show and what our favorite meal was. And you know, Sergio, my favorite was anything with your salsa. I've talked about that a lot. But Sergio, do you actually have a favorite dish for yourself? Like, what is your favorite go-to snack?
但最后一次是瓦尔坦，我相信。是的。我知道有几个人一直问我们关于节目中不同的菜单以及我们最喜欢的餐点是什么。你知道，塞尔吉奥，我最喜欢的是任何加了你莎莎酱的东西。我经常谈论这个。但是塞尔吉奥，你真的有自己最喜欢的菜吗？比如，你最喜欢的零食是什么？
For a snack, I like the chico stick. Oh, yeah? Yeah. That's the one I like. I just can't resist it. When I see it, it's not everywhere, but when it's there, I grab one, you know? But for food, it's tacos, you know? I got to say tacos with salsa and all that stuff.
作为零食，我喜欢奇科棒。哦，是吗？是的。那是我喜欢的。我就是无法抗拒。当我看到它时，它并不随处可见，但当它在那里时，我会拿一个，你知道？但对于食物，是塔可，你知道？我不得不说塔可配莎莎酱和所有那些东西。
I love tacos. I also remember your dessert bar. You talk about action stations, but one time you had like a make-your-own Sunday bar, and it was like amazing. Yeah. And it was like one of the more summer months, and I just remember how good that bowl of ice cream
我喜欢塔可。我还记得你的甜点吧。你谈到了行动站，但有一次你有一个类似自制圣代的吧台，太棒了。是的。那是在夏季的几个月里，我只记得那碗冰淇淋有多好吃
and I got to put all my toppings on it. But was there a standout dessert that people loved? The cookie cake. Yes. That one was a must every day, actually, with ice cream. Yeah. So it was on, you know,
我可以在上面放上我所有的配料。但是有什么人们喜欢的突出甜点吗？曲奇蛋糕。是的。那个实际上每天都是必须的，配上冰淇淋。是的。所以它在，你知道，
it's on a hot shaper. So it's hot, nice and, nice and soft. Oh, yeah. Yeah, that one still hits. But that was, that's the one that for sure, because it wasn't there at the beginning. It got there around, I think season five or something. So once it got there, it was,
它在一个热的塑形器上。所以它是热的，很好，很好，很软。哦，是的。是的，那个仍然很受欢迎。但那是，那是肯定的一个，因为它一开始不在那里。它大约在第五季左右出现。所以一旦它到了那里，它就，
we couldn't take it out no more. It had like this crusty, like I always wanted an edge piece. because it would get nice and crispy around the edge. And that was Steve's favorite dessert. Steve and I would often meet at the warm chocolate chip cookie dish at the end of lunch. And we would kind of laugh. We'd be like, here we are again. So we meet again over a warm chocolate chip cookie dessert.
我们再也无法把它拿掉了。它有这种硬皮，就像我一直想要边缘的那一块。因为它在边缘会变得又好又脆。那是史蒂夫最喜欢的甜点。史蒂夫和我经常在午餐结束时在温热的巧克力曲奇盘旁见面。我们会笑。我们会说，我们又见面了。所以我们在温热的巧克力曲奇甜点上又见面了。
I loved it. Oh, yeah. And also right there in stage three, right? We were, you all, that was so special. was all the cast was, you know, Steve ate there, everybody ate there, the crew and then decisions were made there, birthday party celebrated there. I mean, I love that stage, and I'll never forget it, you know? Yeah, I loved it when they would, the stage was like, picture sort of for people listening, like a big aircraft hanger, and they would open this giant door,
我喜欢它。哦，是的。还有就在三号摄影棚，对吧？我们，你们，那太特别了。所有的演员都在，你知道，史蒂夫在那里吃，每个人都在那里吃，工作人员，然后决定在那里做出，生日派对在那里庆祝。我的意思是，我喜欢那个摄影棚，我永远不会忘记它，你知道？是的，我喜欢他们，那个摄影棚就像，为听众描绘一下，就像一个巨大的飞机库，他们会打开这扇巨大的门，
and then they would have these long tables, and Sergio would be set up, you know, right outside that door and we'd be going through the food line and you'd have your food stations and there was a sort of open air long tables, very communal kind of eating and gathering and you would see people from different departments. You know, you didn't feel isolated like, oh, we just do this one thing and we don't interact. Everybody was like mixing and mingling and talking and asking about each other's kids or, you know, do you have a trip planned? And it was just a wonderful big gathering every day. It was also a great time to like meet crew members' families because families would come up
然后他们会有这些长桌子，塞尔吉奥会设置，你知道，就在那扇门外，我们会走过食物线，你会设置你的食物站，有一种露天的长桌子，非常公共的饮食和聚会方式，你会看到来自不同部门的人。你知道，你不会感到孤立，比如，哦，我们只做这一件事，我们不互动。每个人都在混合、交流、谈论并询问对方的孩子，或者，你知道，你有计划旅行吗？这每天都是一个美妙的大聚会。这也是结识工作人员家人的好时光，因为家人们会来
during lunch and visit. It was that way that like food brings you together, you know? Yes. And it doesn't happen anymore like that in any crew. I mean, it really doesn't, you know, the people in their trailers now and, you know, it doesn't happen anymore. I mean, where everybody, the writers, everybody, there. It's just mingling. That's my favorite moment. They're at stage three, you know. It's just
在午餐期间来访。就是那样，食物把你们聚在一起，你知道吗？是的。现在在任何剧组里都不会再发生这种情况了。我的意思是，真的不会，你知道，人们现在在他们的拖车里，你知道，这种情况不再发生了。我的意思是，每个人，编剧，每个人，都在那里。只是交流。那是我最喜欢的时刻。他们在三号摄影棚，你知道。只是
sitting everybody there. That's right. You know, family members, kids, all that stuff. Yeah. It was cool. It was cool. I think I didn't realize how special that was until I went to work on other projects. And it is sort of like people just kind of grab their food and go. Yeah. I'm so thankful we had that. It kind of felt like Thanksgiving gathering every day. Every day. It did. Yes. Sergio, this was so wonderful.
让每个人都坐在那里。没错。你知道，家庭成员，孩子，所有那些东西。是的。这很酷。这很酷。我想我直到去其他项目工作才意识到那有多特别。这有点像人们只是拿了食物就走。是的。我很感激我们有那个。它每天感觉就像感恩节聚会。每天。确实。是的。塞尔吉奥，这太美妙了。
Yeah. It's awesome. Sorry, I'm a little nervous, but yeah. Oh, you're doing great. Thank you. You didn't seem nervous at all. No, not at all. Was there anything we missed, Sergio, anything you want to share that we didn't cover?
是的。太棒了。抱歉，我有点紧张，但是是的。哦，你做得很好。谢谢。你看起来一点也不紧张。不，一点也不。塞尔吉奥，我们错过了什么吗，有什么你想分享但我们没有涵盖的吗？
It's nice going back to memory lane. And, you know, like last night I saw the last episode and I cried, you know, because we were talking, you know. about it. And I said, let me watch the last episode. Like, you know, last night, I haven't watched it in a minute. It was nice, you know, because it was so real, you know, like the real reactions, everything. I just saw it last night. That's what. And so, you know, it's nice to come back to memory lane. Would you watch the show when it was on, Sergio? Did you guys watch it each week? I started watching it around season three. And then, yeah, during when we were working. And then,
重温记忆之路真好。而且，你知道，昨晚我看了最后一集，我哭了，你知道，因为我们在谈论，你知道。关于它。我说，让我看最后一集。就像，你知道，昨晚，我有一会儿没看了。这很好，你知道，因为它太真实了，你知道，就像真实的反应，一切。我昨晚刚看了。就是这样。所以，你知道，回到记忆之路真好。塞尔吉奥，当节目播出时你会看吗？你们每周都看吗？我大约在第三季开始看。然后，是的，在我们工作的时候。然后，
I'm about to do a rewatch too, though, with you as soon because seeing yesterday's episode made me want to, you know what, I'm going to start this up again, you know? I own them all. Yeah. It'll be nice and doing that through the office leaders. Aw. Thanks, Sergio. Yeah.
我也准备重温了，和你一起，因为看到昨天的剧集让我想，你知道吗，我要重新开始这个，你知道？我拥有所有这些。是的。通过办公室领导来做这件事会很好。噢。谢谢，塞尔吉奥。是的。
We've really loved rewatching the show. It's been so much fun. And plus, just the joy of us getting to reach out and reconnect with so many people who are so special to us like you. No, thank you. you. Thank you. You're special to me, too. Everybody is on the office. Thank you, Sergio. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you so much. Love you too. I think you can just hear in Sergio's voice how special the office was to him and cooking and caring for people.
我们真的很喜欢重温这部剧。这太有趣了。而且，我们能够联系并重新连接这么多对我们来说如此特别的人，比如你，这本身就是一种快乐。不，谢谢你。谢谢。你对我来说也很特别。每个人在办公室都是。谢谢，塞尔吉奥。谢谢。谢谢。非常感谢。也爱你。我想你可以从塞尔吉奥的声音中听出办公室对他来说有多特别，以及烹饪和照顾人们有多特别。
Yeah, we were such a community. When the three of us were talking, I feel like you can see how there were not these, like, distinct cliques of people. We all blended to Yeah. You know, like he said, looking out on all of us eating, cast, crew, family, producers, writers. Yeah. Well, I thought before we go, you guys, we should hear two of these faky PSAs that NBC had you guys do. They live on the DVDs and bonus content. John did two that were food related. Oh. One is titled jelly beans and the other is titled saltines. Let's hear them. After a well-balanced meal or for a well-deserved snack after school, you might want to grab a handful of jelly beans. Don't eat the black jelly beans. They taste disgusting.
是的，我们是一个社区。当我们三个人在交谈时，我觉得你可以看出并没有这些，比如，明显的派系。我们都融合在一起。是的。你知道，就像他说的，看着我们所有人吃饭，演员，工作人员，家人，制片人，编剧。是的。嗯，我想在我们走之前，你们，我们应该听听NBC让你们做的这两个虚假公益广告。它们存在于DVD和奖励内容中。约翰做了两个与食物相关的。哦。一个是标题为果冻豆，另一个是标题为苏打饼干。让我们听听它们。在一顿均衡的餐食之后，或者在放学后作为应得的零食，你可能想抓一把果冻豆。不要吃黑色的果冻豆。它们尝起来很恶心。
It's just my opinion, but it's true. Do you like dark licorice? I do not. I like red licorice. My mom calls it liqueish. Does she really? Yeah. That's so cute.
这只是我的观点，但这是真的。你喜欢黑甘草吗？我不喜欢。我喜欢红甘草。我妈妈称它为“liqueish”。她真的这么叫吗？是的。那太可爱了。
She says, do you want some liqueish? That's adorable. Yeah. Oh, that's like when my mom calls and says, do you want to Facebook, but she means FaceTime. All right, and here's the other one titled Saltine. When you're sitting around with a group of friends, just looking for a way to fit in. Eating six saltines in under a minute may sound like a lot of fun, but it's also really dangerous. So please eat crackers responsibly.
她说，你想要一些“liqueish”吗？那太可爱了。是的。哦，那就像我妈妈打电话说，你想要Facebook吗，但她的意思是FaceTime。好的，这是另一个标题为苏打饼干的。当你和一群朋友坐在一起，只是想找一种融入的方式时。在一分钟内吃六块苏打饼干听起来可能很有趣，但它也非常危险。所以请负责任地吃饼干。
These are great. So cute. And he's so, like, sincere. Yes. Well, you guys, that was all things food on the office. We can't thank you enough for listening. And, of course, a huge thank you to Creed and Rain and BJ and Sergio. And to Josh for coming in and kicking this episode off with us. Everyone, go get Josh and Angela's cookbook. You can make this. It is on shelves right now. Aw, thanks, you guys. Have a good one. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
这些太棒了。太可爱了。而且他，就像，真诚。是的。嗯，你们，这就是办公室里关于食物的一切。我们非常感谢你们的收听。当然，非常感谢克里德、雷恩、BJ和塞尔吉奥。还有乔什来和我们一起开启这一集。大家，去买乔什和安吉拉的食谱。你可以做这个。它现在就在货架上。噢，谢谢你们。祝你们过得愉快。感谢收听办公室女士。
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoe. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. We want to talk to you guys a little bit about new ego protein waffles. It's really good, taste great, plus it's going to give you 20% of your daily protein.
办公室女士是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制片人是安斯利·布比科。Odyssey的执行制片人是利亚·里斯·丹尼斯。办公室女士由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Ruppertree》。我们想和你们谈谈新的Ego蛋白华夫饼。它真的很好，味道很棒，而且它会给你提供每日蛋白质的20%。
Yes, eggo protein plus waffles provide the same great taste of ego that you know and love, plus 10 grams of protein per serving. I made the new ego protein waffles for my kids the other day. they didn't even know that they were protein waffles. They're just the ego waffles that you know and love. I know they have protein. They're just yummy waffles. Yes.
是的，Eggo蛋白加华夫饼提供了你所知道和喜爱的Ego的同样美味，每份还有10克蛋白质。前几天我为我的孩子们做了新的Ego蛋白华夫饼。他们甚至不知道那是蛋白华夫饼。它们只是你所知道和喜爱的Ego华夫饼。我知道它们有蛋白质。它们只是美味的华夫饼。是的。
I mean, listen, I know we're talking about breakfast, but I have shared this before. I like them as an afternoon treat. And when your teenagers come home hungry, guess what's real easy to give them? A little protein waffle. They say you can fuel your morning, but you can also fuel your afternoon. Sure can. Head to your local grocery store to fuel your morning with ego protein waffles and pancakes available at retailers nationwide. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我的意思是，听着，我知道我们在谈论早餐，但我之前分享过。我喜欢把它们当作下午的零食。当你的青少年放学回家饿了时，猜猜给他们什么很容易？一点蛋白华夫饼。他们说你可以为你的早晨加油，但你也可以为你的下午加油。当然可以。前往你当地的杂货店，用Ego蛋白华夫饼和煎饼为你的早晨加油，全国零售商均有销售。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。